welcome to the great gatsby bootcamp
where you're gonna learn how to build
and launch a gatsby site from scratch if
you haven't worked with gatsby before
it's a framework based off of react and
graphql that makes it really easy to
create both websites and web
applications i've been working with
gatsby a lot lately using it for both my
static sites and my dynamic web apps and
i'm excited to bring you this class as
it's a tool i've grown to love i'm
andrew meade from mead dot io let's go
ahead and jump right in
welcome to the very first lesson for the
great gatsby boot camp where we're gonna
start using gatsby in this video in
particular we're gonna focus on three
things one we're gonna learn a little
bit more about gatsby two we're going to
install the gatsby command line
interface and 3 we're going to use that
command line interface to create and run
our very first gatsby project by the end
we'll have our first gatsby site up and
running and that's what we're gonna
build off of and customize throughout
the rest of the boot camp let's get
started with gatsby by pulling up its
website we can find that over at gatsby
js.org
and i want to spend just a couple of
minutes here exploring the tool in a
little more detail as mentioned in the
welcome video gatsby is a static site
generator based on react graphql and
nodejs
now gatsby can do so much more than you
can typically do with a static site
generator and you actually won't see
that term anywhere on the gatsby
homepage so instead let's think of
gatsby as a react framework for building
complex websites and web applications
so with gatsby you're not just limited
to static sites you can also build
complex web apps with data storage
authentication and more so if i'm trying
to build a personal website to make
myself look good to potential employers
i could use gatsby to get that done if i
want to start a freelance web
development business building websites
for restaurants i could use gatsby for
that too and if i wanted to launch the
next startup and i needed to create my
web app i could use gatsby to build that
web app out now gatsby has gotten so
popular because it's really fast and
super easy to work with gatsby has so
many core features baked right in so you
can get started with a new project in a
matter of minutes without needing to
install or customize any build tools
gatsby comes with everything you need to
get started right away and the good news
is that you can further customize your
gatsby projects using one of the many
plugins that it supports these plugins
allow you to add all sorts of new
features to your site both big and small
and don't worry we'll be diving deep
into plugins and how to use them a
little later in the bootcamp now let's
say i'm creating a personal website
using gatsby i want to have a small
portfolio of my projects and i also want
to maintain a blog making myself look
good to potential employers
now for me i want to write those posts
in markdown i like having my content
directly inside of the project itself so
what i want to do is write markdown
posts then i want gatsby to convert
those over to individual html pages for
my site in that case there is a gatsby
plugin that can help us get that done so
all we need to do is write the markdown
posts in new markdown files and gatsby
handles the heavy lifting of converting
those over to html pages using a unified
template so everything looks consistent
in your site
now let's go back to that other example
of someone who's starting a freelance
business targeting restaurants in that
case the restaurant owners want to
customize things they want a blog where
they can talk about new specials and
they also want to be able to update
their menu on the fly whenever it's
convenient for them now in that case
markdown is a terrible choice the
restaurant owner is likely not technical
and does not want to manage content in
markdown they would have to learn about
markdown and code and get and all sorts
of things it's never going to happen
that's why content management systems
like wordpress got so popular it allowed
website owners to easily manage the
content displayed on the site without
needing to write code the good thing
about gatsby is that it can do that same
thing there are gatsby plugins allowing
your content to come from content
management systems like contentful and
even wordpress so you can have a website
powered by gatsby but still allow the
website owner to manage that content
using a nice simple admin interface
where they're just filling out form
fields and clicking save and the new
content magically appears i remember
when i was running my freelance web
development business from about
2011 to about 2015
and everyone you talked to wanted a
wordpress site they didn't want a
wordpress site because they cared about
using php or mysql
they wanted a wordpress site because
they knew with a wordpress site they
could customize the content on their own
now everyone can have what they want
developers can write their sites in a
modern stack using node.js graphql and
react and the website owners can still
manage their content using whatever cms
they're most comfortable with including
wordpress in this bootcamp we'll end up
covering both of those approaches so
we're going to start off creating a
simple gatsby site and getting
comfortable with the basics then we'll
convert that over to a blog powered by
markdown files and from there we'll
convert it over to a blog powered by a
content management system and in this
case we'll be using the contentful cms
to get that done
now let's actually get started with
gatsby the only thing you need installed
on your machine to use gatsby is nodejs
if you don't have node installed you can
grab it over at nodejs.org
and you don't need a specific version
just grab something modern let's say v8
or greater in this case we have v10 and
11 both of those would be perfectly fine
and if you have something slightly
different on your machine that's going
to work fine as well
now to actually use gatsby we have to
install its command line interface
that's going to be used to generate new
gatsby projects and it's available as an
npm module so what i'm going to do is
crack open my terminal and from here
we're going to run a single npm command
that's npm install followed by the g
flag to install the module globally and
the module name is gatsby hyphen
cli at the latest version
2.4.17
now if we go ahead and run this command
it's going to work through the
installation process and once this is
done all we're going to do is generate a
new gatsby project and open it up in
visual studio code or whatever text
editor you want to use
so right here the installation did
complete successfully and to generate a
new project first we want to figure out
where to store the project now if you
have a folder on your machine where you
like to store your programming projects
go ahead and switch to that directory
for this bootcamp i'm just going to put
the new project right on my desktop so
i'll use cd desktop to switch over to
the desktop and from here we're going to
use the gatsby new command
now the new command is going to accept a
couple of arguments first up is the
project name now this project name is
the name of the folder that's going to
get created so in this case i'll call it
something like gatsby hyphen
and the other argument we provide is the
url to the starter we want to use now
gatsby has a few built-in starters
officially released by the gatsby team
and there are hundreds of other ones
created by third-party developers
allowing you to build all sorts of
interesting sites and applications the
goal in this bootcamp is to explore the
fundamental gatsby features and if you
know those you'll be able to work with
and customize any of those other
starters out there so for us it's going
to be the following url
https
colon forward slash forward slash
github.com
forward slash gatsby js
forward slash gatsby
hyphen starter hyphen hello hyphen world
so take a quick moment to run that
command and it's going to do two
important things one it's going to
create that new project folder and pull
all of the starter code in
two what it's doing right now is
installing all of the modules necessary
for your project to actually run once
this command is done we can crack open
the new directory in visual studio code
and get started building out our site
actually before it's even done we can
get that process started so over in
visual studio code i'm going to open up
that new directory now for me i put it
on my desktop and i called it gatsby
bootcamp so i'll crack that open and
right here you'll notice we do have a
set of files and folders showing up and
we will explore all of these in detail
for now all i want to do is run a single
command from the terminal allowing us to
start our site up now in the background
i can see that the command has finished
and we're actually done with the
terminal we're not going to use this for
anything else in the bootcamp all of the
other terminal commands i'll be running
i'm going to run from the integrated
terminal that visual studio code comes
with you can always go up to terminal
new terminal to find the keyboard
shortcut to open up the terminal in vsc
it's definitely a keyboard shortcut i
recommend
now right here we're gonna run one of
the few scripts that gatsby provides if
we open up package.json
we can see under the scripts property we
have six the one that we're going to
start with is the develop script which
allows us to start up the development
server that we can use to run our app
locally and build the project out this
comes with all sorts of great features
like live reload so your changes are
reflected in real time now there are a
few other commands as well we'll be
exploring later in the boot camp but for
now let's start with that develop script
so from the terminal right here in the
gatsby bootcamp project that is npm
run develop when we do that it's going
to try to start up our gatsby project
the default port for that is 8000 and
once this command is done we should be
able to crack open localhost 8000 and
visit our site here it's saying that
things have compiled successfully so
let's crack the site open
in a new browser tab
localhost on port 8000 i visit that and
what do i get i get a small html page
printing hello world to the screen so
there we go if you're seeing this that
means you have successfully created and
ran your very first gatsby project now
for the moment it doesn't do anything
too interesting so let's go ahead and
wrap up by actually customizing what
we're seeing on the page to get that
done we need to focus on the source
directory now we have a lot of other
folders and files in the project we'll
focus on those later in the boot camp
for now the focus is on the source
directory and if we open that up we can
see there is a single directory inside
of there called pages the pages
directory is a very important folder in
your gatsby project and it's actually
the topic of the next lesson so for the
moment we're not going to dive too much
into the details of what it is or how
everything's working if we go inside of
that folder though we can see we have a
single file index.js
this contains the react component that's
rendering the home page right here if i
open it up we can see it's about as
simple as it gets on line 1 we import
react on line three we export a
functional component where we set up a
div with the text of hello world so this
is the content we're seeing in the
browser if i go ahead and remove that
text content i can replace it with
something like the name of the bootcamp
the great
gatsby bootcamp
i can save the file and in real time we
can see the changes reflected over here
thanks to the development server we're
running in the background all right
that's where we're gonna stop for this
one in this first lesson you got gatsby
installed and you also created and
started up your very first gatsby site
in the next lesson the focus is going to
be on gatsby pages we'll talk about
customizing pages and creating new ones
and the focus will be on that pages
directory and the files inside i'm
really excited to get to that and learn
more about why all of this is even
working so let's jump right in to the
next lesson
welcome to the second lesson for the
great gatsby bootcamp where you're gonna
learn how to work with gatsby pages now
in the last lesson we saw that by
default we had this source pages
directory and in there we had a single
file for the single page on our site it
was index.js
which exported a component that
component rendered a little bit of text
and that's exactly what we were seeing
when we visited our static site over in
the browser the great gatsby boot camp
showing up in both locations
so when it comes to page creation the
source pages directory is where gatsby
looks when it's figuring out what static
pages your site needs so all of the
files we put inside of this directory
are going to represent the pages for our
site such as a home page an about page a
blog page and anything else you might
need and that'll all depend on the type
of site you're building to get started
i'd actually like to empty this file
completely and build the page up from
scratch so right here it's gonna start
off the same one thing we'll do in all
of our pages is import react that's
necessary if we're going to use jsx
and react is something we can import as
it's already installed as part of our
gatsby project
from here what we're going to do is
create our react component for this page
as a standalone variable so const index
page you could pick whatever name you
like this is just the one i'm choosing
and what i'm going to do is set this up
as a function this function is our react
component and all we need to do from
here is return some jsx containing what
should get rendered when this component
gets rendered right here
return in parentheses
i'll set up a div
and in there i'll add an h1 header
element with the text value of hello
after that i'll add an h2 and i'll add a
little bio about myself something like
i'm andrew
a full stack developer
living in beautiful
philadelphia
perfect
now that i have this in place i can go
ahead and make sure that this component
gets exported like we were doing before
so export
default followed by the name index page
now there's no need to create the
separate variable and then export it but
this is definitely the approach i prefer
i find it a lot easier to manage my code
so with all of this in place we now have
a new version of the index page if i
save the file i can see that gatsby
compiled a new version of the site and
right over here we have everything
showing up hello i'm andrew a full stack
developer living in beautiful
philadelphia so this is all it takes to
create a page we add a file to the
source pages directory that file is a
javascript file which exports a react
component
now if you're not familiar with the
basics of javascript
or react those aren't topics i dive into
in the bootcamp though i do have courses
for both of those i have the modern
javascript bootcamp which covers
everything you would need to know about
javascript and i have the complete react
web app developer course which dives
deep into react and that entire
ecosystem if you're interested in either
of those i'll include links on the
screen and in the description down below
so what exactly is happening when gatsby
generates our site it starts by looking
in that source pages folder to figure
out exactly which static pages it should
create in this case it sees we only have
a single file which means our site is
only going to have a single page
now the pages you create should indeed
be javascript files and those files
should export react components
gatsby will render that react component
to figure out what should get shown on
the page that's exactly why we're seeing
our two bits of text when we visit the
root of our site at localhost 8000.
now the name of the files in the source
pages directory is also important in
this case we've called our file
index.js
this is similar to how index.html
would be the default page for a website
when you're working with gatsby index.js
in the source pages folder that is your
home page so in this case that's exactly
why that content is appearing
now to create a new page all we need to
do is add a new file to the pages
directory and that's exactly what we're
going to do right now
in total we're going to add three new
pages in this lesson let's go ahead and
get started by adding a blog page to the
site so this is going to be a page where
we will eventually show a list of all of
the blog posts we've written to do that
we create a new file in the pages
directory i'm going to call this blog.js
and like we did with the index.js file
we have to export a react component
which contains the content we want to
render so let's get that done
to start i'm going to import react
remember we need react in order to use
jsx and from there we're going to set up
our functional component
i'll call this one something appropriate
for the blog page like blog page
i'll set this up as a function
and i'm going to return the jsx which
contains the stuff i want to render in
this case i'll also use a root div and
i'll set up a title and some text so the
header for this page is going to be
something like blog or my blog
then down below we're going to set up a
paragraph element and right here i'll
just say something like posts will show
up here later on and that's true a bit
later in this bootcamp we'll actually
get a dynamic list of posts showing up
below the title
now the last thing we need to do is
export the component it's an important
step otherwise gatsby cannot get access
to this function to actually render the
page
right here that would be blog page
exactly as defined up above
now we can go ahead and save the file
and over in the browser we have access
to a brand new page
this page lives at localhost on port
8000 forward slash blog where this part
of the url after the forward slash is
the name of the page file so in this
case i called it blog over here that's
why we have access to forward slash blog
and when we visit that page what do we
get we get our component content i have
my header blog and i have my paragraph
text just below creating new pages with
gatsby could not be easier all you have
to do is add new javascript files to
that pages directory now this bootcamp
is not just you watching what i'm doing
i've also included challenges which
require you to use what you've learned
to continue to build on the site so down
below let's talk about what i'd like you
to do then i'll give you some time to go
off and do it before we work through the
solution together
so the big picture goal is to create an
about page and a contact page so you'll
be adding two new pages to our site by
the end we'll have four in total
step one create that about page you can
include a page title and a bio use an h1
for the page title and a paragraph or
two for the bio
then you're going to create the contact
page for that one include a page title
and your contact details as well
now when it comes to the file names
which end up being the urls you can just
use about and contact finally test your
work once you have that code in place
actually visit those urls in the browser
and make sure you see your pages showing
up so take some time to knock this out
test your work pause the video when
you're done come back and click play
how'd that go let's get to it step one
i'm going to create a new file in the
pages directory for the about page now
i'm gonna go with about as the url
though maybe you wanted to do something
like about me or even just me in this
case about.js
i'll start by importing react
from react and then we'll set up our
component so a new constant about page
or something similar
we'll set up the function itself and
we'll return the necessary jsx like i
had with my other pages i'll have a root
div with all of the content right inside
i'll have an h1 that says about me
then down below i can add a paragraph to
the page as well and i'll say something
like i currently
teach full time
on udemy perfect
so once we have this in place all we
need to do is export that component
export
default about
page and we are halfway done
now that we have the about page created
let's go ahead and move on to step two
and create that contact page so once
again we need to create a new file in
the source pages directory
i'm going to call this contact
so that would be
contact.js and then here we move through
that same process importing react so we
can use our jsx setting up a constant
for that component contact page and then
setting up the component itself and
returning the jsx that should get
rendered on the page
now for the h1 i'll use the text value
of contact whoops not contact page
then down below i'll set up a paragraph
and i'll just say the best way to reach
me is via my twitter which is at andrew
underscore j underscore mead perfect
actually i'll say via that on twitter
excellent
so now that we have this in place once
again just need to export the component
export default contact page and we are
done we have our two new pages which
just equals a new javascript file that
exports a component
now let's go ahead and i'll remove those
challenge comments we'll make sure
everything is saved and we'll move on to
the final step which was to test our
work
so first up i'll swap out forward slash
blog for forward slash about i visit
that and i see my about page which is
awesome from there i'll visit my contact
page
right here that shows up with the
contact details i specified so at this
point we now know how to create pages
with gatsby the next thing we want to do
is figure out how we can link between
those pages it's already getting a
little old manually typing urls in the
browser bar so let's jump right into the
next video and learn how we can properly
link between our pages when using gatsby
now that you have a few pages in place
let's go ahead and link between those
pages now the most obvious way to get
this done would be to use the anchor
element provided by html itself and that
would indeed work so let's start with
the homepage i'm going to navigate over
to index.js the home page component and
in the browser i'll navigate over to
localhost 8000. all we're going to do is
include some text down below like need a
developer then i'll have contact me
which will be a link over to the contact
page so what am i gonna do well over
here i'll add some stuff just below rh2
it'll be a paragraph tag
something like need
a developer question mark
then after that it'll be the link so
here i'm using the a anchor element the
link text will be something like contact
me
and i'll set up the href attribute
to specify the destination that would be
forward slash contact to navigate over
to that page now this is indeed gonna
work i save the file i see my new text
and my link on the home page and i'm
going to click contact me it brings me
over to the page as expected
now this does indeed work but you'll
notice that we went through a full page
refresh the entire page went away it
went to a white screen then the contact
page was loaded in let's see that one
more time so we click the link we see
that flash of content and the new
content appears
that's because we're using the standard
anchor element this is indeed going to
work as a tool to link between your
pages but gatsby actually has a
different way you can link between your
pages which comes with a lot of
optimizations allowing the content to be
swapped out instantaneously so let's see
that in action and the first thing we
need to do is import something new up
above
right here for this import statement
we'll be grabbing a named export so
inside of curly braces that is capital l
link and we'll be grabbing it from the
gatsby npm module now remember gatsby is
an npm module that's already installed
with our project over in package.json
it's listed out as one of our three
dependencies so we're good to go no need
to install anything new and what we're
getting access to is link link is a
react component when we use link to link
between the pages of our gatsby site
there's a whole bunch of optimization
that happens behind the scenes for
example gatsby is going to pre-load the
page content you might be heading to
so if you do click that link it loads
instantly and you no longer get that
flash of content between pages
so down below we'll leave our old
example in place and we'll add the new
one just below it need a developer
then we'll set up our new link using the
link component so right here i'm gonna
set that up
now here we have a separate opening and
closing tag and right in between we put
the text for the link so once again
contact me
perfect
the only other thing we need to do is
specify a prop to the link component the
link component needs the to prop
2 is the path we're trying to head to in
this case it is forward slash contact
exactly like we had up above
so this is the correct way to link
between pages in your gatsby site and if
you're still linking to an external site
like your github profile or twitter the
anchor element is perfectly fine let's
go ahead and see this in action i'm
going to save index.js
over in the browser we'll navigate to
the home page
and right here we see two links the old
one we had before and our new link down
below now let's pay careful attention to
the content as we click the new link i
click it and what do i see i can see the
new content instantly no longer do we
have the flash of content we got when we
clicked that old link so it's a much
nicer user experience
once again when using link gatsby
performs all sorts of optimizations
behind the scenes to make sure the new
content can be shown in what looks like
real time
let's go ahead and remove that first
solution which wasn't working so well
and with that in place we are done with
new content down below a quick challenge
for you to knock out the goal is to add
a couple of new links to the site on the
contact page i'd like you to take that
twitter handle and convert it into a
link to the twitter profile so it should
actually take users away from your site
over to twitter.com now if you don't
have a profile you want to link to you
can just link to any external website
like google.com or something similar for
step two on the about page i want you to
link over to the contact page if someone
wants to reach out based off of your bio
so make sure to include the correct link
there finally test your work actually
pull up the site click both of those
links and make sure they work as
expected for this link the link
internally between two of your pages you
should see the content instantly without
that flash
all right knock it out when you're done
come back and click play
all right let's get to it on the contact
page i'm going to link over to the
twitter profile so right here i do want
that handle in the future so i'll cut it
out copying it to the clipboard
then i'm going to set up the a anchor
element and since we're working with an
external link we don't need to use the
link component
now the text is going to be exactly the
same as what we had before just the
handle itself and the url will be
specified via the href attribute that'll
be https colon forward slash forward
slash then twitter
dot com forward slash the handle which
once again i have as part of the
clipboard perfect
with the link in place we can always set
up the target attribute
setting that equal to underscore blank
and that's going to open the link in a
new browser tab so users aren't
completely redirected away from our site
let's go ahead and test that out over
inside of the browser i should have that
new link showing up i click it it opens
up a new tab and it pulls up my twitter
profile now i can go ahead and close
that and i'm still on the contact page
the next link you needed to create was
on the about page on the about page i
wanted you to link over to the contact
page
in this case we want to use the link
component as we're linking internally so
i'm going to import the named export
link from the gatsby module then down
below we're actually going to use it now
i didn't tell you where to put it so
anywhere is fine i'll just add it down
below my other paragraph right here i'll
add a new paragraph
i'll put the link right inside
the link text can be something like want
to work with me
reach out
and then all i need to do is set up the
to prop for the link component right
here that'll be a string forward slash
contact and we're done
now let's head over to the about page
and make sure this actually works if it
does we'll be all done our challenge so
i'm going to remove those challenge
comments i'm going to save every single
file in the browser
let's go to forward slash about
here we have our new link which is a
good start i click it it brings me over
to the contact page without that full
page refresh which is excellent and now
that we know how to link between the
pages on our gatsby site let's go ahead
and move on to the next video where
you're going to figure out how to create
shared components so imagine we want to
take links to the next level setting up
something like a navigation bar that
shows up exactly the same for every
single page that is the topic of the
next lesson so let's jump right into
that
your gatsby site currently has four
pages and the content for those four
pages is completely unique there is no
shared content we type out everything
the page should render in the component
for that page
now this works really well for unique
content but think about things that are
shared across multiple pages in your
site like a header or a footer this is
not something we want to have to type
out for each and every page we're going
to have duplicate code all over the
place instead we want to create a
separate react component that all of
these pages can use and render and
that's exactly what we're gonna do in
this video together we're going to
create a footer that'll show up at the
bottom of every page on our site then as
your challenge for the video you'll
create a header for the site pages with
a shared navigation so it's really easy
to access all of the content on the site
so let's get started together with the
footer to get started we need to create
a new file for a new react component the
footer then once we have that component
in place all of these pages can import
it and use it where they'd like at the
bottom of the page that'll give us a
shared footer now this new component
file should not go in the source pages
directory since we're not trying to
create a new page we're just trying to
create a component that can be rendered
on every page
so to do that we have to start by
creating the components directory
and from there we're going to go ahead
and create footer
dot js this will be the footer component
now the components directory has no
special meaning the files inside of here
aren't going to do anything unless
they're imported and used somewhere else
and that's exactly what we want
now to stay organized i'll put the
footer all the way over here on the
right let's go ahead and create the
component i'll start by importing react
from react and once we have that in
place we can create a new constant
called footer and that's where i'm going
to store my functional component
and i'll set up the content i'm going to
render in this case it'll be the footer
element as the root element and right
inside of there all i'm going to do is
add a paragraph and i'll put in a little
text like created
by andrew meade you can use your name
there
then i'll put the copyright information
so copyright 2019 now on a mac to
generate that symbol that is option g
i'm not sure what it is on other
operating systems you could always type
out the full word copyright
the last thing to do is to export the
component from this file otherwise we'll
never be able to access it
so export
as the default export footer and there
we go everything in this file is done we
can now import and render this component
on the various pages for our site
let's start with the one page we already
have up that's the contact page
right here i have the contact page
component
to start i'm going to go ahead and
import the footer
so i'm importing the default export
calling it footer and i'm grabbing that
from a file relative to this one so i'm
going to start off with dot dot to get
out of the pages directory where the
current file lives
then it's forward slash components since
i'm looking for a file in there and it's
called footer leaving off the js file
extension
now that we have the footer component
imported it can actually be used on the
page and in this case it's going to make
sense to put the footer at the bottom
where it belongs so right here
just before that closing div
i'm going to render the footer component
now if i save things what do i see in
the background i can see that my contact
page does have the footer which is a
great start
using react components we're able to
compose our pages and nothing we're
doing here is gatsby specific here we're
just using the fundamentals of react so
i'll do the same thing for the about
page
importing the footer from
we're going out of the pages directory
into components and there we have footer
and i'll copy this line to the clipboard
so i can use it for my other files
right here before that closing div we'll
render the footer component
and then let's check out the about page
so i head over to forward slash about
and right here i can see the footer is
showing up which is great
now let's take this over to the other
two pages blog and index
so for blog i'll paste that import
statement in
then just below where we have that
closing div that'll be footer to render
it
and finally for the home page so right
here
importing the footer component and
rendering it near the bottom of the page
content
perfect
the last thing to do is to check those
two pages the blog page and the home
page i'll go to forward slash blog and
the footer shows up i'll go to just the
root and here the footer also appears
now we have a single place to manage the
footer content and if we wanted to
update something like the year i would
simply type it in save the file and now
that change is going to be reflected on
every single page for the site which is
exactly what we want
all right i'm going to change that back
over to 2019 and now it's time for you
to do something similar but for the page
header so let's talk about what you're
gonna do for this challenge the big
picture goal is to create a shared page
header so step one set up a header
component that component should render a
site title so a title for the entire
site and it should include links to all
four pages so this header component is
going to contain our main navigation now
don't worry about creating the perfect
semantic html structure you can just get
all of this content shown to the screen
and as we work through the challenge
solution i'll go ahead and set up the
semantic html markup
down below next up make sure the
component you create gets rendered at
the top of every single page for the
site all four of them then test your
work you should be able to see your
navigation bar and you should be able to
click between all of the links to
navigate to the four pages on your site
so take some time to knock this out test
your work when you're done come back and
click play
how'd that go let's get to it by first
creating the new component so this is
going to be a new component in that
components directory called something
like header so that's header.js
and in here we're going to import react
since we're going to end up using some
jsx to render the header component
and i'm also going to import that named
export link from gatsby as i do want to
set up the navigation links as well
down below we can actually create the
footer constant and set up our function
for the functional component
now i mentioned that your job was to
just get the content rendered to the
screen and not to worry too much about
the correct semantics for this sort of
thing
in this case though we will work through
that together so i'm going to start with
the header element
from there i'll set up an h1
with the text of andrew mead which i'll
use as the title for this site you could
have used any text you wanted to
then we'll focus on the navigation menu
so for this we want to start with the
nav element
then we're going to create an unordered
list
and in there we'll have a list item for
each and every link so this is the basic
structure we're going to use and the
first list item will contain our first
link in which case i'll just link to the
home page so right here
a new instance of the link component
the text is home and where are we going
to we're going to forward slash
down below i can set up another list
item with a second link for this one
i'll go to the blog page though the
order of the links was not important as
long as all four are showing up
then from there it's about followed by
contact so i'll knock out about first
that is going to go to forward slash
about and finally setting up the list
item for our last link
this link going over to the contact page
so to forward slash contact
so this is the basic structure for our
header component the end result is our
site title and four links showing up to
the screen now i actually called this
footer that is a mistake i should have
called that header
just down below let's go ahead and
export our new component so export
default
header and all we need to do from here
is import this file and render it
somewhere on the site and in this case i
want to do that for all four pages
so that is step number two i'll start
with the contact page so right here
actually i'm going to start with the
page showing up which is the home page
so right here in index.js i'll start by
importing the header
from
that's dot dot forward slash components
forward slash header and i'm going to
copy this line to the clipboard so i can
use it in my other page components
just down below as the first thing i
render i'm going to render the header
component and if i save the file i
should see that showing up and it is
here i have home blog about and contact
and if i click one of those links like
the blog link it brings me over to the
blog page which is awesome now the blog
page itself doesn't have a nav menu so
let's fix that
here i'll paste in my import statement
i'll set up the header component and
i'll do the exact same thing for my
other two pages as well
first up is about
rendering the header
and last up is the contact page
perfect
now once we have this in place we'll
have that shared navigation and the
final thing we need to do after saving
the contact file is to test our work so
right here i'm on the blog page i'll go
to home then blog then about then
contact and we can see that on each and
every page we have our header showing up
up top and down below we have our footer
so when we're working with gatsby we can
compose our site of various components
exactly like we're able to when we're
using react in any other context the
only important thing to remember is that
if we're creating a react component
that's not meant to be an entirely new
page that should not go in the source
pages directory in this case we're
putting it in the source components
directory but this directory could be
called anything you'd like its name is
not important
all right that's where we're gonna stop
for this one i'll see you in the next
lesson
in this lesson you'll be taking your
pages to the next level by creating a
single page layout component so you can
think of this video as a continuation of
the last one in the last video we set up
our header and footer and in order to
render them on every page we had to
import them on every page and then
manually set them up in the correct
position four times now that was four
times four four pages as our pages grow
and our layout shifts that's going to
require us to make even more changes to
every single page component what we're
going to do here is set up a universal
layout component that we can easily use
to create a new page with just a couple
of lines of code so let's see what
that's going to look like and how it's
going to help us
to start let's create a new component in
the components directory and this is
something we're going to call layout.js
and eventually this will be the only
component that our pages need to import
in order to get up and running
now we're going to focus on layout.js
and index.js
if we can get the layout to work here
it'll be really easy to add it to the
other three pages so to start let's
create the basic structure of the layout
component right here we're going to
start by importing react from react
then we'll set up the layout constant
right here it's a functional component
where we return some jsx and i'll start
off with a single root div
now down below we'll go ahead and export
this component so that's going to be
export
default layout and we're done well we're
done for now let's actually try to use
this over in index.js and see what
happens
so here's the big picture goal i want to
be able to remove all of the components
that are used on every page and just use
that single layout component instead
so that's the only one i'm gonna end up
importing
i'll import layout
from
dot dot forward slash components forward
slash layout and then we're gonna use it
down below
now here's what that's going to look
like i'm going to recreate the return
statement and i'll remove the duplicate
one in just a second
right here we're actually going to start
by rendering layout and the stuff we
want to put on the page the stuff unique
to the page that goes right inside so
for us what's unique well it's not the
div or the header or the footer it's
just this stuff right inside so i'm
going to copy those three elements
i'm going to paste them into layout and
this is the end goal of what we want
now currently if i remove that duplicate
return this is not going to work as
expected i'm going to save
index.js i'm going to navigate over to
the homepage and what do we have we have
a blank screen
that's because we're passing stuff to
the layout component this stuff right
here but it's not actually rendering it
so what is it rendering it's just
rendering an empty div
well in react we get access to the
content inside of a component via the
children prop and that's exactly what
we're going to use to get all that other
stuff rendered so right here
inside of layout.js
we get our props
and we're going to use one
right here we are going to render props
dot children and i'm just putting that
inside of curly braces to reference that
javascript variable now what is
props.children well it's the jsx passed
in so it is jsx for these three
elements
now all i'm gonna do is save layout.js
over here what do we see we see that on
the home page we now have our home page
content which is a good start from here
we can customize the layout component to
add stuff that's going to be shared on
all pages like that header and footer so
i'll import
the header
from right here that is dot forward
slash header and i'll do the same thing
for the footer
and then finally we're going to use both
of those now the header is going to go
just before the individual page content
so i'll put that right here and the
footer is going to go just after that
content exactly like we had before
the nice thing though is that if i want
to adjust the layout further i no longer
need to go into the individual page
components instead i just adjust the
layout component which now maintains the
page layout and here we go our index.js
file is much simpler it's concerned with
a lot less and over here we have the
exact same stuff rendered to the screen
that we had before i have my header with
my nav links and down below i still have
my footer as well
so using the layout component is just
going to make our lives a whole lot
easier now let's go ahead and integrate
that into the other three pages for the
site
over in visual studio code we can start
with the blog page so right here we no
longer need to import those two things
we're just going to import layout from
dot dot forward slash components forward
slash layout and i'll copy that line to
the clipboard for now
then down below we have to use it so
right here we need to restructure what
we have we render the layout and inside
of there what do we put we put what we
have right here so i'm going to move
that just inside and i'll delete the old
div i had before and there we go the
blog page is now also powered by that
layout having the header and footer set
up behind the scenes
now let's quickly do the same thing for
the other two pages so right here
pasting in the layout import then
setting that up down below
and moving the unique content for the
page so this stuff right here just
inside
and deleting the old structure we had
perfect last up is the contact page so
once again
using the layout
and putting the unique content just
inside excellent
so in the last two videos we had to do a
little bit of restructuring going into
each and every component file which can
be a little bit of a pain at first but
now it's done all of our pages are
powered by the layout and no longer are
we gonna have to move into individual
pages and adjust the same thing in every
page if you find yourself doing that
it's probably something that needs to be
broken out into a standalone component
instead
so over here let's just go to the about
page and the contact page to make sure
everything is working and there we go we
have a basic static site created and
powered by gatsby now we're not done not
by a long shot there's a lot more to
cover and what i want to focus on in the
next few lessons
is styling your gatsby sites so let's go
ahead and dive right into that starting
with the next lesson
you now have a decent amount of content
on your gatsby site spread across four
pages the only problem is that all of
this content is unstyled and looks
pretty terrible in this lesson
you're going to start to learn how you
can style your gatsby sites using css
along the way this video also covers the
process of installing and setting up
gatsby plugins which allow you to
further customize your site in this
lesson we'll be using a gatsby plugin to
enable sas so we can take advantage of
all of the great features of the scss
syntax
but let's get started with some basic
styles getting those applied to the site
in a visual studio code the first thing
we're going to do is create a new place
for our site styles now i'm gonna close
all open editors there's no need to have
all of these files open anymore and down
below in the source directory this is
where we're gonna add a new folder i'll
call this something like styles once
again the name is not important and in
there i'm going to put a new file called
index.css
this will be the start of the styles for
our site and to make it obvious whether
or not these styles are being included
all we're going to do is use the
universal selector to select every
element on the page and we're going to
change its color over to red
now by default we can see these styles
are definitely not being applied nothing
over here is red and this is correct
by default gatsby is not going to load
in any of your style sheets it's up to
you to import them and in this case
we're going to import our base style
sheet from the layout component as the
layout component is used on each and
every page
so all we need to do is set up another
import statement to get those styles
included in the static site that gatsby
generates right here importing
that's going to be dot dot to get out of
the components directory forward slash
styles forward slash index dot css
now with just that one line added we can
save the component and we can see that
these styles are definitely being
applied as everything is read and there
we go we now have a style sheet loaded
in and we could write every style for
our entire gatsby site right inside of
here now that's not the approach we're
going to take we're going to break
things up a little bit but this is a
great starting point before we go any
further
what i want to do is enable a css
preprocessor here we'll be using sas
allowing us to take advantage of the
scss syntax so we can use all of the
great features functions mixins and
other tools it provides now to do that
we are going to use our very first
gatsby plugin you can find a list of all
available plugins on the gatsby site
that's gatsby gatsbyjs.org
and here's the site i had pulled up
earlier in the bootcamp now in this case
we're looking for the plugins page this
allows us to search through all of the
available plugins to find the one we're
looking for now this list includes both
official plugins released and maintained
by the gatsby core team and it also
includes third party plugins written and
maintained by members in the community
so right here the one we're looking for
happens to be an official plugin and if
i search for sas here it is it is gatsby
plugin sas
so currently i can use the import
statement to import a css file but if i
tried to import a sas file or an scss
file gatsby wouldn't know what to do
once we have this plugin correctly
installed and configured it will all
work as expected on the right hand side
we have the documentation for this
particular plugin here we need to
install a few things and add a little
bit of configuration and we're going to
work through that process together so
let's go ahead and set up support for
this by moving into the terminal
shutting down the development server
using clear to clear the output and
finally using npm install
so right here that's npm install
and the first thing we're going to
install is the plug-in that is gatsby
hyphen
plug-in hyphen sas as seen over here so
all of these are the names of the npm
modules
and the other thing we need which is
mentioned in the docs for this plugin is
node sas
so this module is responsible for
actually converting the files down to
regular css and this plugin just allows
us to actually do that from a gatsby
site
now we can go ahead and run this
installation command installing both of
those tools and once that's done all we
need to do is configure our gatsby site
to actually use that plugin it's not
enough to just install the plugin it
actually needs to be configured now this
is done via a file that currently does
not exist in our project but we can go
ahead and create it it needs to live in
the root of our project and it needs to
be called gatsby
hyphen config dot js now there's a lot
we can do in this file as we'll explore
throughout the boot camp one of the core
things we can do in here is configure
the plugins we want to use and that's
exactly what we're going to end up doing
this config file just needs to export an
object but it's important to note that
this is a node.js file so we need to use
module.exports
setting that equal to the thing we want
to export in this case an object now on
here one of the main properties we're
going to end up using in this config
file is plugins plugins is an array and
here we can configure all of the plugins
we want to use
now in our case we only have the one
plugin so we're going to provide that as
one of our items in the plugins array
and all we need to do is list out the
name of the plugin that is gatsby
hyphen plugin hyphen sas we can save the
file and now we're actually ready to use
scss or sas in the project so down below
in the terminal make sure to stop your
development server if it's running
mine's not and then we're going to start
it up again npm run develop and once
it's up it's going to be using this
plugin which means we can now create and
import scss or sas files
so i'm going to do just that what i'm
going to do is take styles.css
excuse me index.css in the styles folder
and i'm going to rename it
i'm going to call it index.scss
then what i'm gonna do is import that
file instead of importing the file that
no longer exists i just add the s save
the layout component and now our site
should be back to a nice working state
here everything is still shown in red
and if i go over to the style sheet i
could change that to blue save the file
and i can see that my change is indeed
being applied with that plugin in place
we should also be able to use all of the
great scss features so i'm going to
create a variable up above using dollar
sign followed by the variable name and
i'll store the green color inside of
there then down below
instead of just providing the color i'll
reference it via that variable so dollar
sign color now this would not work in
regular css but we're not working in
regular css we are in an scss file and
right here i can see that green is
showing up so there we go with a little
bit of configuration adding just a few
lines of code to our new file we're able
to tell gatsby that we want to use a
gatsby plugin allowing us to customize
the functionality for our site
now let's go ahead and wrap up the video
by grabbing a nice base set of styles
we'll be using for the project
you can grab these styles by heading
over to the browser and going to the
following url that's links dot mead dot
io forward slash gatsby styles now this
is just going to redirect you over to a
github gist and here we have a very long
style sheet this is what we're going to
copy over to our project as our starting
point so right here i'll click the raw
button to pull up the raw file content
i'm going to highlight everything using
command a or control a depending on your
os
then i'll copy it to the clipboard and
paste it over here in index
index.scss removing the stuff we had
before
now with this in place we should notice
a pretty big change to how our website
looks
over here what i'm going to do is pull
up the site we'll notice it's no longer
in green which is good and we'll also
notice that it's definitely a little bit
styled we have nicer font families and a
little bit of spacing along with nicer
font sizes now obviously we're not done
styling just yet but using that base set
of styles we'll be able to further
customize the styles for our project so
that's where we're gonna stop for this
video we now know how to add basic
styles into our gatsby project and in
the next lesson we're going to take that
to the next level by learning about css
modules that is my favorite way to style
react components so let's go ahead and
jump right into that
welcome to part 7 of the great gatsby
boot camp in this one we'll continue to
talk about styling our gatsby sites and
the focus is going to be on css modules
css modules are supported by default in
all gatsby projects and it seems to be
the preferred way to style gatsby sites
as it's covered extensively in the
official gatsby documentation
now with css modules we're not learning
a whole new language it is just css with
a slight tweak making it really easy for
us to create complex web applications
without complex styles so let's go ahead
and get started with the basics
let's get started by closing all open
editors and we're going to focus on just
one of our components for the moment
that's going to be the header component
we want to add some styles to this
making the header look a little bit
nicer
now to add those styles we'll be
creating a new style sheet right here in
the components directory i'm going to
call this header.scss
and in here we'll put the styles
specifically for the header so as an
example let's say we want to style the
links here we are targeting all anchor
elements
and then we'll just set their color
equal to a nice gray right here the
pound sign followed by the hex code i'll
use the number nine six times for that
gray color now if we save this style
sheet none of these tiles get applied
since this isn't being imported anywhere
so let's fix that in the header
component we're going to import that
style sheet just like we did in the last
video when we imported this style sheet
into the layout component
so right here import
i'm going to import the following file
that is dot forward slash header.scss
now if i go ahead and save the component
we can see that all of the links in our
header are styled which is a great start
one thing you'll notice though is that
it's actually all of the links on the
site right here the link to my twitter
profile that's styled in gray and if i
go to the home page other links like the
contact me link are also showing up in
gray
so it's important to note that just
because you're importing a style sheet
in a particular component doesn't mean
those styles are scoped to that
component
in this case we are selecting all anchor
elements on the page not just those that
exist inside of the header so this is an
important thing to note now what's the
solution if i want to just target the
links in the header well there are a lot
of different things we could do a simple
approach without css modules would be to
target by class name something like link
then i can use that class name wherever
i want to apply those styles so inside
of the header component
i could add class name
on it to the link
this is the react prop class name and
i'll just set this equal to the class i
picked link and over here in the browser
we now have that gray home link now this
is a great start but it's important to
remember that those styles are still
globally accessible so if other
components in our large application also
want to style their links and they use a
generic class name like link we're gonna
run into a problem where we have styles
for multiple files overriding each other
leaving us with a big mess
now the solution before css modules
existed was to do something like use a
naming convention a naming a convention
that would allow us to create longer
more complex class names though they
were more likely to be unique so
something like header link instead of
just link then if i wanted a link styled
in the footer i could use something like
footer link and so on
so we can't use those generic class
names because there's a high chance of
conflicting styles and the solution is
to have a whole bunch of complex class
names that's not ideal either
the solution we're going to use to solve
this problem is css modules css modules
make all of the class selectors in the
module style sheet locally scoped which
means that we have to manually import
them and use them and we'll see what
this means in reality in just a second
for now let's notice one thing we have
our two files saved and that home link
is gray
all we're going to do is enable this
file to be a css module by changing its
name we're going to change the file
extension
down below i'm going to rename it to
header
dot module dot scss
now you could also use header.module.css
if you did not want to use the scss
syntax though in this case i'll keep it
in place
now right away our app crashes and
that's expected we're trying to import a
style sheet that no longer exists so
let's adjust the name here
dot module dot s css
now if i save both files it's no longer
crashing but you'll notice that our link
is also no longer gray i have the class
name link right here and i'm also
targeting it over here in this file
that's loading so what's going on as
mentioned earlier when we're working
with css modules our class selectors
they are no longer globally applied
instead they're locally scoped it's
something we need to import as part of
the import statement and then apply
directly to that element so let's see
what that looks like the first thing we
need to do is change our import
statement i'm going to comment out the
old one and add a new one just down
below
here on importing the default export i
can call it whatever i want i'm going to
call mine header styles and we're
grabbing that from the same file dot
forward slash header
dot module dot scss
so when we're working with a css module
we actually get a default export this is
an object which contains properties for
every class we've defined in the module
in this case we just have one link so
what we have is an object with a single
property link we can use that property
to apply that style
so no longer are we going to have a
static string for the class name it's
going to be dynamic so class name equals
inside of curly braces the following
header styles
dot link where link is the name of the
class chosen over here
now if we go ahead and save the header
component we'll see that once again our
link is gray everything is back to
working as expected and the great thing
about css modules is that we're being
explicit i'm explicitly loading in a set
of styles from a specific file and i'm
applying them directly to the element so
there's zero chance of some sort of
global style coming in and messing
things up from another component and
that's what we want we want our
components to be self-contained and easy
to update and work with
so now that we have this in place let's
take a look at what exactly is happening
over in the html for the site i'm going
to open up the chrome developer tools in
the browser you can always go to the
menu more tools developer tools to find
them
and here i'm looking for the elements
panel and i'll use this selector by
clicking it and picking an element on
the page i'm going to click that home
link and it's pulled up down below
now here we can see we do have the class
attribute and there is a single class
inside of there but it's not something
we ever created it is header module
followed by link followed by a random
series of characters this is the class
name generated by the css module that
keeps our styles unique even though
we're using a generic class name like
link
we could target links in other
components in our project by using the
exact same selector without any chance
of overriding the ones in the header
so now that we've seen how css modules
actually function let's continue working
with them to style the rest of the site
to get started i actually want to add a
css module for the layout component so
right here
in the components directory that's
layout.module.scss
and we're going to crack open the layout
component as well
and i'll just stay organized up above
with the header stuff then the layout
stuff let's get started adding a few
styles to the layout allowing us to
center the content on the site so it's
not all pushed up against the left hand
side let's start with a new selector
selecting the container class and right
here we're going to set up a few basic
styles starting with the margin i'm
going to use 0 and auto to center things
left to right
and we're also going to set up a max
width for the site i'll use something
like 750 pixels
and finally a little bit of padding on
all four sides so the content isn't
pressed up right against the edge of the
browser
right here one rem should get the job
done now we have to import this module
in the layout component and actually use
those styles
right here
import
layout styles from
dot forward slash layout.module.scss
and once we have that in place we can
apply that to our div right here
so this one
is going to have a class name equal to
on the layout styles object we have that
container property now if i go ahead and
save things we can see all of our
content has disappeared because it's now
centered in the browser which is
obviously a nice step in the right
direction
another thing we're going to do with the
layout is set up a sticky footer so
right now the footer kind of gets pushed
up the page especially on shorter pages
it would be nice if it was always at the
bottom of the site
to get that done the first thing we're
going to do is create another div inside
of the layout component
so right here let's set up that new div
element
and we're going to put the header and
the page content inside of there the
footer is going to be just outside of
the div and this is a common html
structure for a sticky footer
right here we'll end up applying a few
styles to this div
let's get started over in the layout
module
inside of the container we need to add a
few new styles in order to get
everything working the first thing we're
going to do is set up display setting
display equal to flex we're going to
enable flexbox here
and the flex direction for the container
is going to be vertical since we want
the content and the header above the
footer not left and right
so right here we're using column as
opposed to the default value which is
row i don't want the footer on the right
i want it on the bottom
the last thing we're going to apply to
the container is min height setting that
equal to 100 vh this is the viewport
height so here i'm setting the container
height to the screen height
now that's the minimum height so it
could always get bigger on longer pages
and that's what we want
only other thing we need to do is style
that new div we created i'll set up a
class content for this with flex grow
set to 1
that's going to allow that container
this container right here to grow as
needed leaving just enough space for the
footer in place
so the layout module is all done we have
our styles in place
over here all we need to do is apply
the class name prop to that new div
layout styles dot content i save the
program and over in the browser we can
see we have the sticky footer in place
so on the contact about blog and home
page that footer stays where it's
supposed to
now if the site content was shorter it
wouldn't be at the bottom still you'd
still have to scroll to see it which is
exactly what we want
so now that we have the layout styles in
place let's go ahead and head back over
to the header as we are going to add a
few more styles here so inside of the
header module let's get to it first up
i'm going to add another class selector
for header to add a little more space
for the header
right here padding
is going to be one rem on the top zero
on the left and the right and 3 rem on
the bottom so we're just trying to put a
little space between the header content
and the other stuff on the page
now if we head over to the header
component we can apply that right here
so class name equals
that's going to be header styles dot
header perfect
now over in the browser those styles
should have taken effect and they did
perfect
now let's continue on to the h1 shown on
the header i actually want this to be a
link to the home page as well
so what i'm going to do is set up the h1
and put a link right inside
this link is going to have the same text
i had before so the text value will
still be andrew mead
and we're going to send them to the home
page so this is like clicking a site's
logo and going to the home page i want
to be able to do that same thing here
so if i'm on the contact page i click
the name and i go to the home page
now clearly we have to add some styles
to that and that's exactly what we're
going to do
so in the header module we'll set up a
new class selector for the title and
right here we're gonna do a couple of
things first up setting the color equal
to black that is the hex code with six
zeros
then we're gonna set the font size equal
to 3 rem making it a little larger and
finally setting text decoration
to none removing the underline effect we
get with links by default
now let's apply this to that link so
right here
class name equals
header
styles dot title
i save the program and over in the
browser we can see that this is still a
clickable link
but it's now styled to look like regular
text and you could swap that out with a
company logo or whatever you wanted to
next up let's focus on styling the
navigation
list so we can get rid of those bullet
points and put the items left to right
as opposed from the top to bottom
approach which we currently have in
place
to style that we'll be styling our
unordered list right here
in the header module a new class
selector
nav list and we're going to apply just
three styles first up display flex this
is going to stack those items left to
right which is what we want
i'm also going to set up list style type
sending it equal to none that's going to
remove the bullet points which we don't
want
and finally i'll set margin to 0 to
clear the default margin values that our
lists typically get
over in the browser we can see that none
of our changes have taken effect i
forgot to apply that in the component so
right here
class name
is going to equal
header
styles
dot
nav list
so here we have a camel cased version of
what we typed out in the css and our
styles are applied perfect
the next thing we're going to do is add
a few more styles to the individual nav
items we added just one as an example
but we're going to add a few more
right here i'm also going to change the
selector i'll change it from link over
to something like nav item
now the color is going to stay in place
i'm also going to adjust the font size
setting it to 0.9 rem a little bit
smaller than it currently is
i'll also add a margin on the right so
the items aren't jammed right up against
each other
1.3 rem on the right and finally text
decoration
setting that equal to none once again to
remove that underline effect we were
getting
now we can use this for all four links
in the navigation so right here i'll
take that first one and i'll swap it out
from link over to nav item and down
below i can just copy this class name
and definition for the other ones
one
two and three
and i can see i have a little auto
formatting from my visual studio code
editor perfect
now let's save the program over in the
browser what do we get we have a nice
styled header i have my links to my
pages sitting below the header text
which is also clickable
now when we're using css modules we can
still use pseudo classes or anything
else we might want to use
so let's say that on hover we want to
adjust the color of the link item we can
do that
nav item
then colon hover
so when someone hovers over that with
their mouse we'll just change the color
to something a little darker right here
hex code is six six times
perfect
now we can test that out over in the
browser i have my links showing up i
hover over them and i can see they're
getting a little bit darker which is
exactly what we wanted
one more thing we can do with the link
component is set up a class name that
should get applied when we're on that
specific page so if i'm on the contact
page i could style this link differently
giving the user a visual cue as to where
exactly they are in the site
down below let's go ahead and get that
done i'll set up something like active
nav item for that
and all we're going to do is set the
default color to something even darker
this will be the number three six times
a nice dark gray
now let's actually apply that over in
the header component then we'll be all
done for styling
so over here we have class name for all
of the links if you want to set up a
special class name for when you're on
that page you use active
class name
so right here i would be setting that to
header styles dot active
nav
item perfect so right here just matching
up with what i had to find over here
now let's take that definition and move
it to the other ones we have just down
below our other four links
so i'll add it to the blog link
i'll add it to the about link and to the
contact link and once we have all of
those in place we'll be able to test our
work
right here i'm going to save the program
right here i can see i'm on the contact
page and the contact link is darker than
the others i go over to the about page
that's dark blog home
so now we have a nice navigation system
letting the user know exactly where they
are on the site all right that's where
we're gonna stop for this one now that
we have some styles in place we're done
with what i would consider part one of
the boot camp where we cover the basics
of creating a site with gatsby in the
next video we're going to start talking
about how we can get dynamic data into
our site using gatsby's graphql api so
let's jump into that
welcome back to the great gatsby boot
camp in this video we're going to turn
our attention towards getting dynamic
data into our gatsby sites using
gatsby's graphql api
now if you've never used graphql before
that's perfectly fine we'll only be
using a little bit of graphql with
gatsby and we'll go over the basics as
we use them
so right now everything shown in the
browser is something that's only showing
up because it's typed directly inside of
the jsx for a react component all of the
nav items the site title every bit of
text showing on the screen
now obviously that's fine as we're
getting started but as we do want to
create more complex dynamic sites this
approach is no longer going to scale as
an example let's say we were going to
introduce the blog to our gatsby site
without using anything new without using
the graphql api
creating a blog post would require you
to add a new page to the pages directory
for every single post and you would end
up with a lot of duplicate code and you
would end up writing your blog posts
right inside of the jsx for the
component which is never ideal that's
not an easy way to get your thoughts
down on paper and organized when you
have to manually maintain the html
structure along the way
the other downside is that you'd also
have to update the blog page so your
posts showed up here you would have to
manually copy titles and excerpts all
over to this page to create a list of
all your posts so well it's possible
it's not ideal and it's not something
we're even going to attempt instead
we'll focus on getting data via the
graphql api that gatsby provides
now the best way to visualize this is
actually on the home page of the gatsby
site
that's over at gatsby js
if i scroll down just a little bit
there's a section called how gatsby
works now there's a chance this
visualization changes over time but i
think this is a pretty great
visualization for what's happening here
everything we're working with so far
sits below this line right here so yes
we're using gatsby and we're working
with html css and react and we're also
getting a version of our site up and
running now we're not deploying it to
production we're running it in
development but it's the same idea and
we'll get to the deploy stage a little
bit later in the boot camp the only
thing we haven't touched on is what's up
above the data sources for your gatsby
site so where does your data come from
when it's not typed directly inside of a
react component it could come from a cms
like contentful or wordpress
it could come from files on the file
system in the form of markdown blog
posts it could come from any third-party
data source such as a custom api you've
created
so this is what makes gatsby really
powerful we can pull in all of this data
using gatsby's graphql api
allowing us to create what is still a
static site but that static site gets
generated with dynamic data from
third-party data sources now we will
progress to more complex data sources
like cms's and markdown files but we're
going to start with one of the easiest
built-in ways we can set up dynamic data
in our gatsby sites and that is via
what's known as site metadata it's
nothing more than an object on there we
can put key value pairs for whatever
we'd like as an example the site title
maybe the twitter profile name and the
author of the site anything like that
that we'd want to be able to easily
adjust across the entire site
now to get that done all we need to do
is go into visual studio code and make a
change to that gatsby config file we've
created so for the moment i'm going to
close all open editors and we're going
to open up just the gatsby config file
and we're going to add another property
onto this object just alongside of
plugins
and in this case i'll call this site
metadata and the name here is important
it needs to be exact otherwise gatsby's
not going to be able to find it let's
get started by setting up a title
property for the site title i'm going to
call mine something like full
stack boot camp perfect
you can choose whatever title you'd like
for your own site let's also set up one
more property on site metadata i'm going
to set up an author property which i can
use throughout the site and right here
the value for that will just be andrew
meade so there we go we have two pieces
of data and we'll add more onto site
metadata later in the video for now
though let's figure out how we can
actually query this using the graphql
api that gatsby provides once we've
pulled these values into our components
we'll focus on adding more and more data
now let's actually fetch this data using
gatsby's graphql api and to start we're
going to head over to the browser open a
new tab and we're going to pull up a url
that's only available when our site is
running in development mode right here
that is localhost on port 8000 like we
had before
then it's forward slash underscore
underscore underscore
graphql so that's triple underscore
graphql
this is going to pull up a tool called
graphyql which is an in-browser ide for
exploring a graphql api so if you've
ever worked with a rest api before maybe
you've used tools like postman or
insomnia this is the same idea just for
a graphql api
so we type our query over here in the
left hand side we click that play button
it runs the query and we get our data
over here on the right hand side so we
can use this to mess around with all of
the data we have access to figuring out
exactly what we need and where it lives
once we have our query and we're getting
back the data we want we can move that
query into a react component to actually
set things up in the gatsby site for now
we're going to start by using graphyql
to mess around with the basics of
graphql once we know how to fetch the
title and the author will actually bring
that into a react component to wire that
data up dynamically if you haven't
worked with graphql apis before one of
the great things about them is that
they're self-documenting graphql uses an
explicit schema and tools like graph eql
can show you that schema letting you
know exactly what data you have access
to and how you can get it so for us
let's crack open this docs panel on the
right hand side now in graphql there are
three main operations we can perform
queries mutations and subscriptions when
it comes to graphql inside of gatsby we
just use queries to fetch the data from
those external sources
so right here let's go ahead and click
on the query and we can see a list of
all of the queries we have access to
there are quite a few and this list is
actually going to change as we move
through the class later on there'll be
new queries for fetching markdown pages
or for fetching content from a cms
for now the one query we're going to
focus on is near the bottom of the list
and it's just called site
so i'm gonna click on site we can see a
few different things about the site
query i can view the arguments we can
provide we're not gonna provide any and
i can view the type definition which is
what we want so when we grab site what
do we get access to well if i click that
we get access to all of these fields i
have quite a few different fields the
one that we're interested in is called
site metadata
now if i click on site metadata i can
see that is of the following type i
click on that and i can see what fields
i have access to title and author the
two things we defined over in site
metadata over here
so let's go ahead and actually run a
query to fetch this data now i know we
clicked through a lot of screens but
once we see the query in action it'll be
a lot easier to figure out what's going
on so step one is removing the comments
over there and starting by defining our
query we do this by listing out query
then we open and close a set of curly
braces and inside of here we can perform
whichever of those queries we wanted to
in this case we decided we wanted to use
site so i set up site opening and
closing a pair of curly braces and in
here we can list out everything from
site we want access to for us it was
site meta data
now this alone is not going to work we
can't just grab everything from site
metadata we have to be explicit grabbing
just the fields we're actually going to
use
so we set up another pair of curly
braces and i list out what i want access
to in this case title and we can see
we're even getting a little
autocompletion i can always use that to
populate the final value and there we go
our very first graphql operation we are
performing a query called site on site
we're grabbing site metadata on site
metadata we're grabbing title and if i
click that play button to run it what do
i get over here i get my data back i can
see full stack bootcamp showing up now
one thing you'll notice about the
response is that the structure of the
response is dictated by the structure of
the query here we have site site
metadata and title
here we have site site metadata and
title so we get back exactly what we put
in though the fields we requested are
obviously populated with the correct
values
so now that we've seen a basic query
let's go ahead and run this exact same
query from a react component so we can
fetch dynamic data into our site we're
going to focus on grabbing the site
title like we're doing here but we're
actually going to populate it as the
value that shows up in the header up
above
now for us that means we need to make a
change to the header component so right
here let's crack that open
this data right here is going to end up
becoming dynamic and to get started we
have to grab two new things from the
gatsby library alongside of link
the first thing we're going to grab is
called graphql and the second thing
we're going to grab is called use
capital s static capital q
query
using these two things we'll be able to
perform a graphql query getting access
to the data then we'll be able to inject
the data right in the jsx down below so
let's do it let's start by creating a
variable called data to store the data
we're fetching from the graphql api
then we're going to call that use
static query function this is going to
allow us to query our graphql api
now we're going to call it as a function
and inside of there we're going to
provide a tagged template literal so
right here we're using a template string
but just before the template string
we're using graphql which is a function
so this is a syntax called a tagged
template literal essentially it allows
this string to be processed by that
function and in this case it's going to
convert our string graphql query over to
something that can actually be used a
complex abstract state tree with all
sorts of object properties and stuff
that we just don't need to worry about
so for us what we type in this string is
exactly character for character what we
were typing over in graphql
so it's a query
in there we're using the site query i'm
asking for the site metadata and on that
i want the title
now we're done we have access to that
data and we can go ahead and use it in
the link down below or wherever else we
might want to use that data
so for us i'm going to remove andrew
meade in the h1 in my header
and we are going to set up some curly
braces so we can inject the value the
value is on data
dot site
dot site
meta data and it is title
now if we save the program we can
actually pull our site up and what do we
see i see full stack boot camp showing
up in the header which is fantastic we
were able to create a react component
that fetched data from gatsby's graphql
api to come up with something that's
dynamic
now what's cool is that as that data
changes the site will also change
so over here i'm going to alter that
title adding an exclamation mark on to
the end
i'll save things head over to the
browser and i can see that change is
already in place
so this is one way we can access some
dynamic data in our gatsby sites using
site metadata this is great for key
value pairs like title author your email
address social media urls and that sort
of thing
so once again inside of header what did
we do we worked with use static query to
perform a query we got access to the
data and we injected that somewhere in
the jsx
now that we've done this once together
it's going to be your challenge in the
video to do it again on your own just up
above i'm gonna paste in the challenge
comments and your goal is to run another
graphql query fetching the other site
metadata we have
so step one use graphyql in the browser
to fetch the author making sure you get
the correct value back once you know how
to fetch the author update the footer
component to display the dynamic author
value instead of the static one so right
now andrew meade that's hard-coded in
the footer component i want this value
to come from the site metadata instead
once you have that in place you're gonna
test your work so actually make sure
that you can see the name show up and
when you change the name in the gatsby
config file you should see it change in
the browser as well
so take some time to knock that out
pause the video test your work and when
you're done come back and click play
how'd that go let's get to it with step
number one so over here in the browser
we're going to use grapheql to fetch the
author so once again that lives on site
metadata alongside of title so right
here instead of accessing title i'll
access author
i'll run the query and i can see that
value showing up so this is what i need
to run from the footer component let's
go ahead and get that done
over in visual studio code i'm going to
crack open the footer component and
we're going to import those two things
we need from gatsby right here that was
graphql
and
use
static query
grabbing both of them from
the gatsby npm library exactly like we
were doing over here
from there we can actually use these in
the footer
const data equals i'm going to call use
static query
i'm going to use graphql
with a template string and we're going
to provide our query the query is using
site from there we're grabbing site
metadata and on site metadata all i want
access to is the author
now we should have access to the author
and i can use it down below so i'm going
to remove the static author and swap it
out with a dynamic value
that would be data
dot site
dot site metadata dot author and we're
done
now that we have this in place let's
test our work i'm gonna save the footer
component in the header component i'm
gonna remove those challenge comments
and save that file too and hopefully i
see andrew meade in the footer
right over here i do
now let's actually change that value in
gatsby config just to make sure it's
showing up so i'll swap this out with
something else like the author
save the file head over to the site and
that's what's showing up in the footer
so now we have two dynamic pieces of
data in the site and we figured out how
to use gatsby's graphql api which is a
great step in the right direction
all i'm going to do to wrap up is revert
that change back to a value that makes
sense and we're done
in the next video what i want to do is
take just a couple of minutes to show
you an alternative to grapheql that you
can use with gatsby in my opinion it's a
lot easier to work with and comes with a
nicer user interface i'm excited to get
to that so let's jump right in to the
next one
welcome back in this video as promised i
just want to take a couple of minutes to
explore how you can set up an
alternative to graphyql
this is the default ide for working with
your graphql api in gatsby but gatsby
also comes with support for another ide
known as graphql playground it's a lot
newer and comes with a much nicer
feature set including some what i would
consider essential features
now to swap out graphql for graphql
playground
all we really need to do is set an
environment variable on our machines and
we're going to do this in a cross os
compatible way so right here we can
close all open editors we don't even
need the source directory for this video
and we're going to focus on package.json
now this could be as easy as setting up
the environment variable right here in
the script the problem with that is it's
not cross os compatible so instead we'll
create an environment variable in a
separate file which will load in a very
common approach
so right here a new file in the root of
the project called dot env
dot development
in here we're going to define our key
equals value pairs for the environment
variables
now in our case we just need one
the name is gatsby
underscore
graphql underscore ide
and the value we want is playground
that's going to enable graphql
playground support giving us that new
tool in the browser so now that we have
this in place the only thing we need to
do is actually load this file in when
we're using the development server and
to do that we'll use the very popular
env cmd npm package
down below in the terminal i'm going to
use ctrl c to shut down the development
server
then we'll use npm install
with the save dev flag since this is a
dependency we only need in development
and from here we're going to go ahead
and set up the following env cmd
so let's go ahead and install this and
once it's installed we're actually going
to work it in to our package.json
so inside of package.json
what are we going to do we're going to
change the development script right here
it's going to use envcmd
to load that environment variable file
in then it'll run gatsby develop
right here we're going to modify this
script that's going to be emv hyphen cmd
the new tool we just installed and from
there all we're going to do is provide
the name of the file we've created
dot env dot development
and we're done now it's going to load
those environment variables in then run
the gatsby server
so let's save package.json
in the terminal down below we're going
to start it up like we've done before
npm run develop and once it's up and
running all we're going to do is refresh
the
page over here and we should see
something quite different i'll go ahead
and give it a refresh and we can see
it's loading an entirely new interface
here we have graphql playground now it
comes with the same set of features i
type my query over here i can run it and
see the response but it's a lot easier
to work with we can manage tabs so we
can have multiple queries at the same
time we also have a nicer set of docs
that in my opinion is much easier to
work with so here we have site
then we can see all the arguments and
our fields below site metadata title and
author so we can see everything in one
shot making it a lot easier to construct
the queries we want to perform so that's
it for this video i just wanted to show
you how you could set up support for
this new tool going forward i'll see you
in the next one
a couple of videos ago we went over to
the browser and went to the gatsby
homepage to look at the following
visualization here we talked about how
we were going to use the graphql api
that gatsby provides to source our data
from external data sources
now so far we have done that with site
metadata we were able to pull in some
basic information getting that rendered
in our react components but it's not
exactly a great place for more complex
data for example the blog posts we're
trying to create for our site storing
that inside of that little site metadata
object just is not realistic instead
we're gonna start to focus on creating a
blog powered by markdown blog posts so
inside of visual studio code we'll be
adding markdown files for each of the
blog posts we want to create
those will then be listed over on the
blog page of our site and we'll also
have gatsby dynamically generate brand
new pages based off of a page template
for each and every blog post so that's
the end goal let's get started by
writing a couple of posts
in visual studio code what we're gonna
do is put our blog posts in the source
directory for the moment we can collapse
the other directories inside of there
and we can also close all of our open
editors we're going to create a brand
new folder in the source folder and i'm
going to call this posts you could call
it something else like blog or blog
posts the exact name could be whatever
you want
in here we're going to add a couple of
posts i'll have one called
gatsby.md
and real quick i'll create another one
let's call it react.md
so for the gatsby post we're just going
to add a little bit of sample text i'm
not actually going to write out an
entire post
let's get started by adding what's known
as the front matter for our markdown
posts so we start with three hyphens we
end with three hyphens and right in
between we can add key value pairs for
whatever makes sense for us now for
posts you might want to include the post
title maybe the date the post was
published a list of tags the author
whatever sort of data you want to add
onto the actual post content
so right here let's keep it simple i'm
going to set up a title for this post so
that is title colon space inside of
quotes i'll call this the great
gatsby bootcamp
then down below i'll also set up a date
right here
2019
the fourth month and the fourth day
then we can just put a little bit of
content on the screen so right here i
just launched a new boot camp
then i'll set up a second header using
two hash signs followed by a space
for a new section i'll call that topics
covered
then down below i'll just list those out
so i have gatsby as the first one i'll
go ahead and put graphql in there and
last up is react so there we go we have
some front matter and we also have our
blog post content itself with a couple
of things for markdown that should end
up becoming different in terms of how it
looks on the screen i would expect this
to be a small paragraph and this to be a
large header
now let's go ahead and do the same thing
for the react post so right here we want
to set up that front matter
the title for this one can be something
simple like react and i'll set the date
to an earlier date so right here
i'll use 2019
the fourth month but the second day so
two days ago
then i'll add the content below
in this post
you'll
learn react perfect
so what do we have we have a blog with
two posts the gatsby post and the react
post what we need to do is figure out
how to get this inside of gatsby because
once it's in there we need to transform
it from markdown to html and we need to
get that rendered to the screen
step one though is to tell gatsby that
we're now sourcing content from an
external source it's coming not from
site metadata not from a cms not from a
third-party api it is coming from the
file system everything we need is right
here in the posts folder there's a
plugin that's gonna let us get that done
let's head over to the browser and go
back to the gatsby site if we scroll up
a little bit we're gonna head over to
the plugins page and we're gonna use the
search bar to just search for source
right here we're going to see all of the
gatsby plugins that allow us to source
data from an external source for example
bigcommerce a postgres database custom
apis instagram google photos
vimeo trello and more
now in this case we're not trying to
source from any of those our content
lives on the file system so we're trying
to source it from the file system right
here
source hyphen file
system is going to bring up the gatsby
plugin that we're going to use
so this plugin is going to allow us to
pull those markdown files into gatsby
then a little bit later we'll use
another plugin to convert them from
markdown to html we can actually render
to the screen
let's get started though by adding this
plugin into our gatsby project and
getting it configured
so over here we're going to shut down
our current development server i'll use
clear to clear the terminal output and
we're going to install that new plugin
so npm install
that is gatsby
hyphen source hyphen file
system at the latest version 2.0.28
i'm going to run the command it is going
to set that up and all we need to do is
enable it by adding it to our plugins
array over in the gatsby config file
now we've only worked with one plugin
before and it didn't require any
customization i simply listed out its
name as a string and that was enough to
get the job done
with the file system source plugin there
are a few options we have to provide so
the setup looks a little bit different
let's add a second item onto the plugins
array and this second item is not going
to be a string it's actually going to be
an object
now when we set up a plugin as an object
we still have to provide the plugin's
name and we do that via the resolve
property so right here as the value for
resolve we type in the plugin's name
that is gatsby
source
file system and there we go
this is identical to what we have above
the only advantage is that now we can
expand on that object adding what the
file system plugin needs which is an
options object
on options we have to provide two things
both our strings
first up is a name we can pick source
for this
and the second is the path to the
directory on the file system that we're
trying to source our content from
so right here that's path and we're
going to use a template string to get
the job done
to start off let's interpolate a value
that is double underscore der name if
you're not familiar this comes from
nodejs and remember this is a node.js
file that's why we're using
module.exports instead of the export
syntax
and after der name all we have to
provide is forward slash source forward
slash
so with just this little bit of setup
we're now telling gatsby to source
content from the file system this
includes everything in the source
directory which would also include our
markdown posts
now that we have this in place let's
start up that development server once
again so down below
npm run develop
and what we're going to do is head over
to graphql playground and i want to take
a look at exactly what's been added with
the addition of this plugin because
there are two new queries we now have
access to
so over in the browser
we'll go back over to the playground and
give things a quick refresh
if we head over to the docs we're gonna
see we have two new queries that did not
exist before
we have a file for fetching an
individual file
and we have all file for fetching
multiple files let's go ahead and use
all file to explore some of the files in
our project right here under type
details we can see we have edges that's
what we want edges makes it possible to
perform pagination
and in there we have access to node
node represents an individual file and
here we have a bunch of information
about the file that we're currently
requesting we could request its size the
extension the absolute path when it was
created the directory the name all sorts
of interesting things show up inside of
here
now remember this did not exist before
because we were not sourcing content
from the file system now that we are we
can actually use that right here in
graphql playground and that's exactly
what we're going to do so i'm going to
remove our current query by removing
everything from inside of it and we are
going to use all file
and from there as mentioned we're going
to grab edges
and for each edge
we have the node and in the node we have
access to whatever we want about that
file let's go ahead and grab the name
the file's name we're also going to grab
the extension
finally i'll choose to grab the
directory as well using dir
now if i go ahead and run this we're
gonna see a list of every single file in
our source directory with these three
pieces of information so here i have
about with the js extension that's
sitting in the pages folder that's
correct below that i have blog and
contact i have our index page the header
component the footer i have our css
files in there as well and if i scroll
to the bottom i can see that amongst
those other files i have my gatsby
markdown post right here and down below
i have my react markdown post so now we
are correctly sourcing content from the
file system from here the question is
how do we specifically target these
markdown files and how do we take their
contents and convert them into something
that's useful for us
inside of react components
so this is just step one of about three
steps to getting the markdown blog up
and running in the next video you're
gonna learn how to transform these
markdown files into html you can
actually use and render i'm excited to
get to that so let's jump right into the
next one
welcome back to the great gatsby boot
camp now that we have the gatsby source
file system plugin set up we have pulled
in files from the file system allowing
us to access them via gatsby's graphql
api in this video we're going to take
that to the next level what we want to
do is target just our markdown posts and
we want to parse them from a file like
this into content that's actually useful
i want to be able to pull out things
like the title the date and the post
body so i can render them to the screen
we're going to get started with that
process in this video and to start we're
going to use another gatsby plugin that
pairs with the gatsby source file system
plugin so this is going to load those
raw files from the file system the
plugin we're about to use is going to
look for markdown files in there and
it's going to parse them into useful
data we can find this by heading over to
the gatsby plugins list
right here if we go ahead and search for
something like remark we should find the
one we're looking for it is gatsby
transformer remark
so we used a source plugin to pull
content from an external source
now we're using one of the many
transformer plug-ins to transform that
content into something useful and this
plugin could not be easier to use there
is zero configuration we just install it
set it up and we have access to our post
data so let's see what this looks like
in visual studio code i'm going to shut
down the terminal use clear to clear
that output and we're going to install
it that's npm install
gatsby
transformer
remark at the latest version which is
2.3.8
now if you're wondering what remark is
that's a standalone javascript library
for parsing markdown files so all we're
doing here is using a gatsby plugin that
runs that library behind the scenes i'm
going to go ahead and run the installer
and up above we can set this up in our
plugins array
at the end of the array we're going to
add a new item and this is just going to
be a string with the plugin name
gatsby transformer remark there's no
need for any options like we had up
above as this plug-in doesn't require
any configuration
now that we have this in place we can
save the config file the installation
has completed down below and all we're
going to do is start up our dev server
once again so npm run develop and once
the server's up and running we'll
actually be able to access our parsed
markdown posts via the graphql api i'll
be able to extract the front matter i
want as well as the html for the blog
post body so let's see that in action
over here we have graphql playground i'm
going to give things a quick refresh and
if we crack open the docs under our
queries list you'll notice down at the
bottom we have two new ones i have
markdown remark and all markdown remark
the first one is used for fetching an
individual post the other one is used
for fetching a list of posts and that
would be useful for something like the
blog page where i might want to show all
of the posts i've ever published with
the most recently published ones up top
so to get started we're going to use
this query to fetch some data about
every single post we've created now in
this case we just have two
i'll crack open a brand new tab
we're going to set up the query
we are going to use all mark down remark
then we can take a look at what exactly
we have inside of there and the
structure is really similar to the
general structure over here with edges
and node in the docs
down below all markdown remark we have
edges
we have node and node contains things
about our post we have the front matter
this is where we can access the title
and the date and anything else we choose
to add and we also have access to things
down below like the html for the post
the excerpt and all sorts of interesting
information like time to read which is
calculated based off of the post's
length so let's go ahead and actually
grab some of this data in our query over
here
that's edges
node
and in there let's just start with the
title so the title is in front matter
we're gonna grab the title
i'm gonna fire off this operation and
what do i see i can see i have two posts
the first with the title of react and
the second down below with the title of
the great gatsby boot camp
from here we could grab additional
information like the date
outside of front matter but still in
node i could also grab stuff like the
html or an excerpt depending on what
exactly i needed in this case let's grab
both
i'll fire off the operation and right
here we can see we have the parsed html
for our post and an excerpt we could
show
in our list of posts
now this post was pretty simple but if i
scroll down we can see there's a more
complex html structure for our more
complex post i have the paragraph i have
my header i also have my ordered list
with the list items that i set up so all
of this markup is based off of what we
put in those markdown files
now that we actually have access to this
data via the graphql api we can run
queries from our components to pull this
data in and use it to render a list of
the posts available getting that done is
gonna be your challenge for the video so
let's talk about what i'd like you to do
over here we're gonna move into the
pages folder in there we have the blog
file this is where you're gonna spend
your time for the challenge and i'll
paste those challenge comments in just
above
so the big picture goal is to show a
list of posts on the blog page now for
the moment we're not worried about
linking to any other page where the
whole post is showing and we're not even
worried about rendering the post body
all we want to do is render the title
and date for each post so to start down
below you're going to need to query the
graphql api fetching the title and date
for every single blog post using what we
just talked about over in graphql
playground
then in the page down below you're going
to render an ordered list using the ol
element from there inside of the ol
element you want to render a list item
for each and every post
the list item should have a nested h2
header tag for the title and a paragraph
tag for the date
now if you don't remember how to take an
array of objects and convert that into a
list of jsx elements you can google
something like render array of objects
react and that'll get you to the right
place and get you the information you
need to jog your memory
now there's no need to do all of this at
once before ever testing things out test
it in stages run the query use
console.log to print the data to the
terminal make sure that looks good and
get comfortable with the structure of
the data then use what you've learned
there to actually get stuff rendered to
the screen
finally test your work on the blog page
of the site i should see my two post
titles react and the great gatsby boot
camp both with their dates just below
alright knock that out test your work
and when you're done come back and click
play
all right how'd that go if you ran into
any trouble along the way the good news
is as always we're gonna work through
the solution together now i said the
solution more like a solution as there
are plenty of different ways you could
have structured this
now step one is to query that data and
we can't do that without importing a few
things from gatsby we need graphql and
we also need use static query grabbing
those from the gatsby library and once
we have both of those in place we can
move into the function for our blog page
component and actually set up a query
similar to what we have over here we
need the title and we need the date
so const data is going to equal
we'll call use static query providing
graphql along with our template string
and in here we're going to have
essentially the same thing we have over
here but without html and excerpt which
aren't needed so right here let's knock
that out
we'll start with query
we're trying to use the all
markdown remark query
then we're going to go ahead and grab
edges
from there
node
from there we need the front matter
which contains all of the data we're
looking for and we want title and we
also want date
perfect
so now that we have the query in place
let's just use console.log
and dump the data to the terminal to
make sure this part is actually working
as expected if we get the correct data
then we'll move on to steps two and
three actually rendering it on the page
for now though i'm going to head over to
the blog page i'll crack open the chrome
dev tools right here i have the console
and down below i have an object this is
the data variable we have all markdown
remark and we have our edges array where
each edge represents a post
right here one of the posts as an
example has that node property we then
have front matter and on there we have
date and title so the structure we're
getting back here is the exact same
structure we got back over here now
let's actually use that to render some
content to the screen
so remember step two was to set up an
ordered list and i'm going to do that
down below
i'll remove the paragraph
i'll set up the ordered list and inside
of here we want to put a list item for
each and every post we found that means
we want to iterate over that edges array
and we want to take the edges object and
we want to convert that to a list item
so let's actually get that done
right here setting up some curly braces
and we're going to access that array
that's data
dot all
mark down a remark exactly like we just
saw in the terminal
from there we grab edges and that's an
array now we have an array of objects
and what we want is an array of jsx
elements so i'm going to use the map
function to convert the object over to
jsx
now in this case our function gets
called one time for each edge so one
time for each blog post
and right here we'll get access to the
individual object which i'll just call
an edge
now it's the job of the map function to
return some jsx this is going to show up
for each and every post so right here we
start off with a list item and i
mentioned in there i wanted a header to
tag
and i also wanted a paragraph so i'll
set those up as well
now all we need to do is pull the title
and the date off of edge and put them
right inside of these two elements
so we'll start with the title
over here we can see that for one of the
array items we have the node property
then front matter then date and title so
that means over here it would be edge
dot node
dot front matter
dot title and with this in place we
could test our work so far to make sure
at least the title is showing up and it
is right over here i have react followed
by the great gatsby boot camp next up we
have that paragraph and i want to put
the date right inside of there
that'll be edge dot node
dot front matter
dot date identical to what we had up
above just accessing something different
from the front matter
now we can actually remove the
console.log call as we're all done we
have successfully fetched the data and
used it to render a list to the screen
if we check things out in the browser we
have our list item one the title is
react and the date was april 2nd and
here we have the great gatsby boot camp
post with the date april 4th
with this in place we've made some
really great progress towards what we're
working towards now this page is not
done yet we do need to link over to a
blog post page and eventually we're
going to include some additional
information here
but this is a really good start
next up over in the terminal all i'm
gonna do is close down excuse me delete
the challenge comments and that's where
we're gonna stop for this one we have
our query which is fetching the markdown
post data
down below we're using some jsx and
javascript to get everything rendered
now the question is how do we create a
new page for each and every post i
mentioned what we're not gonna do
is manually add new files to the pages
directory instead we're going to use a
gatsby api that's going to allow us to
dynamically generate new pages with
dynamic content so we'll be able to
generate new pages where the page
content is the blog post content
i'm excited to get to that and we'll be
starting that in the next video so let's
go ahead and jump right in
now that we have a list of blog posts on
the blog page it's time to dynamically
generate pages for each and every post
so if i want to read this post i click
on the title that brings me over to a
new page and that new page is
dynamically generated
using the markdown data from graphql and
a blog post page template which is
nothing more than a react component and
we're going to use that same blog post
page template for every single blog post
since as we saw in graphql we have a
standardized set of data i have a title
i have a date and i have the body
content for each and every post
now let's head over to visual studio
code close all open editors and i'm just
going to crack open a new file where i'm
going to outline what we're going to
cover in this video the reason i'd like
to outline things is that we'll be
spending a little time working with the
internal gatsby api and that can be a
confusing topic so it's a good idea to
have the big picture in mind goal number
one is to generate a slug for each post
so let's say we have a post like our
gatsby post that is gatsby.md that is
the markdown file what we want to do is
generate a slug which is nothing more
than the file's name stored as a string
gatsby that's going to allow us to set
up the url where someone will be able to
view this post now that url could be
whatever we like for example it could be
forward slash gatsby or something a
little more complex like forward slash
blog forward slash gatsby either way
though we need the slug from the file
name in order to set up the correct
endpoint where that particular post
should be accessible so that's goal one
generate a slug for each post
goal two is an easy one for us we are
going to generate the blog post page
template that's nothing more than a
react component and there's not a lot to
say about that for now pretty
straightforward
next up and the final thing we're gonna
do goal number three
is to actually combine those two so we
want to generate
a new page for each post so in order to
generate that new page we're going to
need a template and we're going to need
access to the file and the slug so we
can set up the correct url where someone
will be able to view our new dynamically
generated page
so those are the three goals and to get
started what we're going to do is
actually create a new file that
currently does not exist in our project
in the root of the project
this file is gatsby
hyphen
node.js this is the gatsby node
configuration file which allows us to
tap in to a lot of the node apis that
gatsby exposes
this is what we're going to use in order
to generate that slug and in order to
dynamically generate those blog post
pages before we start using these
internal apis let's check them out over
in the gatsby docs so you know where you
can learn more i'm going to head over to
the gatsby website
we're looking for the docs page
here we need to scroll all the way down
in the sidebar and go to api reference
once we're there we're looking for the
gatsby node apis these are all the
things we can define in that new file
we've created
and on that page if we scroll down just
a little bit
we get brought to a list of all of the
different apis we can tap into
using that new gatsby node file now in
this video we'll end up using two of
them and the first one we're going to
use is on create node this is what's
going to allow us to attach some new
data on to the individual node and what
we're going to do is attach the slug so
we have access to the slug throughout
the entirety of our application if
you're wondering what a node is remember
it's nothing more than a data structure
for storing your gatsby data and we
already saw this in place with the
graphql queries that we ran in the last
couple of videos so right over here we
have the all markdown remark query we
grabbed the node to grab individual data
about the particular markdown node here
we grabbed the front matter html and
excerpt and there were other fields
which we didn't grab but were available
so that is the individual node this api
allows us to do something when that node
is created so when a new markdown node
is created all we're going to do is
attach the slug field onto it and that's
nothing more than a string the file name
without the dot md extension so right
here we're going to take this code and
bring it over into that file now this
file is indeed a node.js file so right
here what we're going to do is set up
module.exports exporting the very first
thing on
create
node so that's how we use this file we
export functions and these functions get
registered to gatsby and run when
they're supposed to in this case our
function runs when a new node is created
now over in the docs we saw we get
access to an argument and we can
destructure that to get access to the
node and to some actions which are
destructured down below
now we don't need create node but we do
need create node field so we're going to
make sure to grab that as well
right here
let's destructure this argument grabbing
the node and grabbing our actions
then down below i'll destructure the
actions grabbing
create
node field
from actions and there we go we have our
little boilerplate version of the
function in place
now it's time to actually see what this
is going to do for us and how we're
going to use it to generate the slug
field first thing i'd like to do is just
use console.log to print the node to the
terminal so we can see what exactly we
get now when we use just this it's not
going to print in a way that's easy to
see so let's pretty print the node
instead with the following
here we're just going to use
json.stringify
to convert the node object over to a
formatted string that'll make it a lot
easier to view things down below
so right here how do we call stringify
while we pass in the object as the
second argument we provide undefined
this is an optional filtering function
in this case we want to see everything
so we'll leave that off and the final
argument is the number of spaces we want
to use when printing it to the terminal
in the formatted version here i'll just
use four
so now we're going to see a pretty
printed version of the individual nodes
when we restart the server because
that's when oncreate node runs
so down below let's shut down the
terminal i'll use up and enter to
restart the server and when we restart
it we're going to see our console.log
call print a bunch of new objects to the
terminal which is exactly what we got
the first object right here is quite
large it runs from up above it contains
about two dozen different properties and
it runs to down below
now the only thing we're concerned with
about this object is internal internal
itself is an object and on there we have
a type property this is the type for the
current node and in this case we can see
the type is site page site page is a
built-in gatsby type this is for new
pages on our site and right here we can
see this is for index.js in the pages
directory and that is our home page
now if we continue to scroll up we'll
see site page nodes for the other pages
we've defined so up above we have site
page for contact
then we have site page for blog followed
by site page for about
then we have a page that's generated for
us
site page for dev404 page now don't
worry you're going to learn how to
create a proper 404 shortly
but past that that's where things start
to get interesting up above we have a
new node and the internal type is
markdown remark these are the nodes that
we actually want to tap into so oncreate
node runs for all of the nodes for our
gatsby site we don't want to do
something for all of the nodes i just
want to do something for the markdown
remark nodes i want to take that entire
file name i want to reduce it to a slug
and i want to add that as a new field
onto the node so it's easily accessible
throughout the rest of our app so that's
exactly what we're going to do here we
have the node for the react post up
above we have the node for the great
gatsby boot camp which also has an
internal type of markdown remark
so to take this to the next level we're
going to set up an if statement
we're going to look at the nodes
internal type
when it equals
markdown remark then and only then are
we actually going to do something now
for the moment we can just take our
console.log call and move it inside of
there to make sure it's still running
when expected so i'm going to save the
file i'll restart the dev server down
below and now i should still see some
logs print but i should only get two one
for each of those posts right here i
scroll up the first one is an internal
type of markdown remark which is great
above that we have our other post and
above that there's nothing so no longer
are we seeing the nodes for our site
pages and that's what we want we've now
successfully targeted just the nodes
we're actually trying to manipulate
now if we head back to the node up above
we'll see there's one particular field
that does contain the entire file path
that is file absolute path that's
available on both of our nodes
and this is what we're going to tap into
we're going to take this we're going to
remove the entire path except for the
file then we're going to remove the
extension leaving us with just the slug
in this case gatsby or in the case up
above just react
now there's actually a nodejs module
built in called path which allows us to
manipulate the path and that has a
function which allows us to extract the
file name from a complex path like the
one we've seen
so we can find the documentation for
this at nodejs.org
here we want to go to docs
once we're on docs we want to pick a
version the api we're using is pretty
standardized so it'll be the same no
matter which one you pick
we're going to scroll down to path
these provide a bunch of different
methods for manipulating string paths
and we're looking for one called base
name
base name takes an entire path like this
one here and it reduces it to just the
file name and the extension
we can use the second argument however
to remove the extension leaving us with
just the file name and that is exactly
what we're trying to do
so let's go ahead and close down the
documentation here and actually get that
done
up above i'm going to load the built-in
path module
const path comes from requiring path
there's no need to install it as it's a
node core module and down below what
we're going to do is try to get access
to the slug
so constant slug is going to equal
we'll be using path dot base name like
we just saw in the docs
we're going to provide the path and we
saw that on node
file absolute path
and then as the second argument the
extension.md
which we're trying to remove and that
should leave us with just the slug let's
actually see if that's the case
i'm going to remove the old console.log
call and add a new one into the mix
right here i'll print a bunch of at
signs to make this easy to find in the
long list of terminal output
then as the second argument i'll print
the actual slug
so i'm going to save gatsby node
i'm going to shut down things from the
terminal and i'm going to start them up
once again and hopefully we see our
little message printing twice once for
each markdown post right here i did see
them move by i have the first one with
the slug of gatsby and the second one
with the slug of react so we've
successfully extracted the data to get
the slug now we have to call create node
field to actually add the new field onto
the node and this one really isn't too
bad down below we'll remove that
console.log call
we're going to call create
node field and we need to provide an
object with three different properties
the first is the node we're trying to
create the node field on
now here i'm using the shorthand syntax
to set the node property equal to a
variable of the same name
then down below we need to set the name
for our new field i'll go ahead and use
slug for this and finally the value what
is the value for slug well i have that
stored in the slug variable and that is
it this is all we need to do to achieve
goal number one of adding the slug on to
our markdown nodes
now let's go ahead and test this out so
i'm going to restart the project from
the terminal for the final time and
instead of looking at something from a
console.log call we're actually going to
try to grab the slug for our posts over
in graphql playground so over in graphql
playground we can go ahead and check
things out right here we have the node
with the front matter html and excerpt
based off of the new stuff we just set
up we also have something called fields
and fields has a single field that is
the slug perfect
now if we actually run this we're gonna
see that for each post we do get a slug
right here we have the great gatsby boot
camp we have the slug of gatsby and down
below we have the react post with the
slug of react so there we go that is
goal number one achieved we've
successfully created a slug for all of
those blog posts the next two goals are
what we're going to focus on from here
on out now originally i was going to
have this all as one video but let's
take a moment to take a break as this
went on a little longer than i wanted to
but i wanted to move through the
individual steps using
console.log so we could actually see
what we were doing with this code over
here
so that's it for this one in the next
video we'll wrap things up by setting up
the template and actually dynamically
generating those new pages i'm excited
to get to it so i'll see you then
it's time to continue on with our three
goals we already have our page slugs
goal number two is to generate a new
template for the blog post page and
we're going to do that by creating a new
directory in the source folder called
templates
now the reason i'm creating a new folder
is that i want to differentiate the
react component we're about to create
from the standard components in the
components directory or the specialized
components in the pages folder here
we're working with page templates and
those are going to work slightly
differently so we'll create this new
folder
in there we'll put a new file i'll call
this blog.js
and in here all we need to do is create
and export a react component the
template for our blog post pages so
right here let's start with the very
basics i'm just going to import react
from react
then down below i'll set up the blog
component which is just a function
and i'll have it return some static text
now i'm actually going to put that text
inside of a layout so let's import
layout real quick as well
importing
layout from dot dot to get out of the
templates directory forward slash
components forward slash layout now we
can use it and actually render some
content to the screen so right here
layout
in there this is the blog template
now you'll notice that we're not
rendering anything specific about the
post like the title the date or the
actual body we'll work on that in just a
little bit for now we just want to get
the basic template file in place down
below
export
default blog and we're done
so we have the template in place for
each and every blog post page that is
goal number two
the third goal is to generate a new page
for each post and that's going to
require us to use another api from
inside of the gatsby node config file we
can check this out over in the api docs
so right over here what i'm going to do
is scroll to the top of the node apis
page back to that table of contents
and the one we're looking for is
actually the very first one as of now
create pages
create pages gives us everything we need
to dynamically generate new pages for
the site
now down below we can see exactly how
this works don't worry we're going to
work through all of this together and
we'll actually be using a slightly newer
syntax to make life easier
what i really want to focus on are just
these two lines right here we export a
create pages function and gatsby gets
access to that function and runs it a
single time
and we destructure that first argument
to get access to graphql and actions
graphql is going to allow us to fetch
some data in our case we want to fetch
those markdown nodes which contains the
data we need
and on actions we get access to an
action for creating a new page
so let's go ahead and actually set this
up then we'll work through the rest of
the function getting everything in place
so right over here inside of the gatsby
node file
module dot exports dot that's going to
be create
pages with a capital p
and this is just a regular old function
now i am going to destructure that first
argument like we saw them do in those
api docs
the first thing we have access to is a
graphql function it's actually a little
different than what we've been importing
from gatsby in the past
and the second thing we get access to
are a bunch of action functions in this
case just one right here we're going to
grab that it is called create page and
we're going to call it for every new
blog post page we're trying to create
right here i'm just destructuring that
from actions which is itself an object
so down below we can now take advantage
of this api to dynamically create the
pages and we need to do three things one
get path to template
two
get markdown data
and then finally three
render excuse me not render create new
pages so these are the three things we
need to be able to do and the first one
is super easy we just want to get the
path to that new template we've created
that's blog.js
i'm going to store this in the following
variable i'll call it something like
blog template and this is going to be a
path an absolute path to that file on
your machine starting way back from the
root of the hard drive
and to do that we'll use path dot
resolve that'll resolve a partial path
which will provide as a string right
here
now for us this needs to be the path
from our current location in the gatsby
bootcamp folder to the destination which
is blog.js
so that's dot forward slash source
forward slash templates forward slash
blog.js
the resolve function itself is going to
add everything up front to create an
absolute path from the root of the hard
drive
now the next thing we need to do is
actually fetch the markdown data we need
access to all of those slugs so we can
dynamically create these new pages
now we already know how to query those
we've done just that in graphql
playground and we're going to use a
similar query inside of the node file
now we don't need to grab anything
except for the slug so the operation
we'll be performing is going to look a
little bit like this the end result is
that we get a bunch of edges with the
slug defined for each that's all we need
now let's head over to the file and talk
about graphql
this is not the same as the graphql
we've been importing from the gatsby
module in files like our header
component this is actually a function
itself that we pass a string graphql
query2 right here that's going to be
graphql we're going to pass to it a
template string and in here we just type
out the query we want to perform exactly
like we have over in graphql playground
so it's a query that is all mark down
remark
from there edges from there node from
there fields and finally slug
so this is what we need to provide in
order for everything to get fetched
correctly
now you'll notice that we're not doing
anything with the return value
this function actually returns a promise
so we have a couple of different options
i can add a then call down below to get
access to the value that eventually
comes back or i can use async await
which is what i'm going to do so right
here
we're going to mark this function as
async
then
i'll set up a new constant response and
i'll be awaiting the promise from this
function
now unfortunately i can't dive deep into
async await in this particular video as
i want to stay focused on graphql if
you're not familiar with the syntax
though it is nothing more than a way to
make a promise api look a little more
unasynchronous so right here we have
some very synchronous looking code down
below we can now do something with the
response
now what exactly are we going to do well
we want to iterate over all of those
posts and we want to run that create
page function for each of them so right
here we have our response
we have data
we have all
markdown remark
and on there we have edges
now we're going to use the for each
array method to run a function
this function right here for each of
those now if we have an array of edges i
could call the individual element
something like an edge
and now inside of here the goal is to
call create page
so i'm going to call create page
and i'm going to provide to it an object
and on here we have to provide three
things first up is the component we're
trying to render now the component is
not an actual react component it is just
the path to the component and we already
have that up above i have the blog
template string which i'll use down
below
the next thing we have to add on here is
path so we're creating a new page but
where exactly should someone be able to
access the page we're creating for
example forward slash test would be
localhost 8000 forward slash test
in our case though it's going to be
dynamic based off of the slug that each
post has
so i'm going to use a template string
that's forward slash blog forward slash
the slug so right here inside of the
template string will interpolate the
following value
that's node excuse me edge.node
then we're going to grab fields and
we're going to grab the only field we
have slug
so now when i visit forward slash blog
forward slash some slug i'll see that
blog post page rendered
down below just one last thing that is
context
context is an object and this contains
stuff we can pass down to that template
now in our case the only thing we really
need is the slug if that template has
the slug it can fetch the rest of the
data for the post like the title the
date and the body content so right here
we're going to pass the slug through
which you could consider kind of like an
id as it is unique for each and every
post and right here we'll just use the
following that is edge.node.fields.slug
once again
so this is going to run twice creating
two new pages the first is forward slash
blog forward slash react and the second
is forward slash blog forward slash
gatsby
both are going to be rendered using the
template we've defined and both will
have access to a little extra data which
they can later use to pull everything
they need about that blog post
now that we have this in place we're all
done i know that this in-depth
configuration can be a little dry
but if you are interested in using
gatsby being comfortable with create
pages and with oncreate node is
essential for doing what we've just done
here this exact same stuff is just as
essential if you're pulling your data
from a cms like we'll see a bit later
for now though let's test things out
down below i'll shut down the server
i'll start it up once again and we're
actually going to try to visit one of
those two pages let's start with forward
slash blog forward slash react
over in the browser i'll head back over
to the gatsby site here we're on the
blog page now we don't have links to our
post pages yet so we'll have to manually
visit them i'll go to forward slash
react first
if i visit that what do i see i see this
is the blog template which is awesome if
i go to forward slash gatsby what do i
get i also get that blog template and if
i go over to something else like forward
slash node what do i get right here i
get a 404 page
so there is no node blog post but if i
were to create it this particular page
would exist and we would actually be
able to view the blog
so let's go back to one of the post
pages that did exist and there we go we
now have a way to dynamically generate
pages now we're not done yet there's
still two very important things we want
to do on this page we actually want to
render the post content and on the blog
list what i want to do is link to the
individual blog post pages now that
second task is something you already
know how to do so that's going to be
your challenge for the video then in the
next one we'll focus on pulling in the
individual data to the template
component
so for the blog page what you want to do
is actually create clickable links for
each and every post that heads over to
the correct url
so let's talk about what i'd like you to
do we don't need any of these files any
longer including our little goals list
as we've completed all three of those
the only file you're going to need is
the blog page and just up above i'll
paste in the challenge comments so the
goal is to link to the blog posts in the
list that we're rendering down below
now right here to get that done first
you're going to need to fetch the slug
for each post by modifying our query
down below
then you need to use that slug to
generate a link make sure to use the
link component provided by gatsby and
you want that to go to the correct
location so forward slash blog forward
slash slug
finally test your work actually pull up
the page in the browser click those
links and make sure it brings you over
to the correct blog post page
all right take some time to knock out
those three steps test your work when
you're done come back and click play
how'd that go let's get to it and the
first thing i'm going to do is grab the
link component from gatsby as i know i'm
going to need it a bit later down below
we want to make sure we fetch the slug
for every single post now we have that
query right here
inside of node alongside of front matter
we want to grab fields and in there we
want to make sure to grab the slug so we
can actually use it when creating our
links destination
now down here when it comes to modifying
the structure i didn't give you any
specific rules for how to create the
link or what to put inside of it so for
now anything works what i'm going to do
is set up the opening tag for link right
here
and i'll put the closing tag below the
paragraph making both of those clickable
perfect
now all we need to do after indenting
things is to set up the two property and
this needs to be dynamic there is no one
static destination it is based off of
the static text forward slash blog
forward slash and the dynamic text
stored in that slug field and for us
right here that would be the following
edge dot node dot fields dot slug
so there we go we have our link in place
and hopefully it's working as expected
before we actually test this out i'm
going to remove the challenge comments
up above
save the component file and now we'll
make sure our link is working
over here i have the blog post page and
i am seeing links for both posts if i
click the react one i'm brought over to
the react page if i go back to the blog
page and click the great gatsby bootcamp
i'm brought over to forward slash blog
forward slash gatsby which is awesome
so at this point when it comes to the
markdown blog there is only one thing we
need to do we need to figure out how to
actually use the slug in this template
to fetch the data the title the date and
the post body because all of that needs
to get rendered to the screen
that's what we're going to do in the
next video so let's jump right into that
in this video we're finally going to
render the post content on the post page
replacing our little placeholder text
with actual data about the post like the
title the date and the post content now
to get this done what we need to figure
out how to do is how we can set up a
dynamic graphql query this query needs
to accept the slug and it needs to give
us back the data for the associated blog
post so over here in our template file
what we have access to is the slug and
we can't just have a static query we
need a dynamic query that actually takes
that slug value into account so to get
this done let's start in graphql
playground i'm going to crack open a new
tab we'll figure out how to use graphql
variables and arguments and once we know
how to use them we'll actually integrate
that into the blog post page template
you can view the docs to see exactly
which query we're going to use down
below we've already used all markdown
remark to get a list of posts here we're
going to use markdown remark to get a
single post now up above we have the
call signature we have the query name
followed by the list of arguments
followed by what we get back which is
markdown remark and here we can see the
type details of that and we've already
used this sort of stuff fetching things
like the front matter the html or the
fields and that's stuff we're going to
end up grabbing
if we keep scrolling down though to the
arguments list
this contains all of the different ways
we can target the post we're trying to
fetch and in our case we're going to
target it by its fields so i'll be using
the fields argument and in there the
only field we actually have is a slug
and there are a few different ways we
can target it we're going to use eq
which is short for equality that will
allow us to target a post by its slug
value let's actually get that done i'm
going to collapse the documentation and
we'll set up a sample query right here
let's get started with the query in this
case that is mark down remark
from there we're going to provide our
selection set what exactly do we want to
grab
in this case let's just grab the title
so that's front matter accessing the
title when we actually wire this up in
the component we'll grab more data so we
can render it for now though we actually
have enough in place to run this if i
run it what do we see we see we're
getting back an individual post the
great gatsby boot camp being the title
so by default if we don't provide any
search criteria it's just going to
return the first post it finds now
that's not particularly useful for us we
want to target it by the slug value and
to do that we have to set up arguments
for our query
the arguments come right after the query
name and you could list them out right
here on the same line but it's common to
break those out into separate lines like
so
and inside of parentheses we can specify
the arguments we want to provide in this
case the only one we want to provide is
fields so that's fields colon space
followed by the value
now in this case the value is an object
because we want to target by slug that's
also an object and in there we want to
target by equality
now this is just a string right here we
can target by any of our slugs for
example react
so now we're fetching data about an
individual post but it's targeting a
specific one and if i run the operation
i can see i'm getting the data for that
post back which is great
now i could change this over to gatsby
and i could run that and we get that
data and i could change it to gatsby
with two y's which does not exist and in
that case we get null as there is no
post with that slug
so this is the basic idea of what we're
trying to accomplish
now that we know about arguments for our
queries the one other thing we need to
talk about is query variables
query variables is nothing more than a
set of data passed into your query your
query can then use that to populate
things like argument values
so when we type out our operation in the
component we don't want this data in
line this is static we want it to be
dynamic so down below when we're using
graphql playground we can provide query
variables by just clicking that item at
the bottom and setting up some json so
right here i'm going to set up one key
value pair
i'll have the key be slug and the value
will be the slug value like react this
is exactly what gatsby is going to do so
it's important to understand how these
work
now what we need to do is set up our
query to actually accept that variable
slug and we define that right here after
the query keyword inside of parentheses
in this case like we did down below we
start with the variable name prefixed by
a dollar sign so that would be dollar
slug to match up with what we have down
below
then we define the type for slug so we
have to be explicit about that and in
our case that would be string that's
capital s string dollar sign
now i'm not going to dive into the
details about all of the other types
that graphql supports there's a lot of
great content out there on graphql and i
also have a udemy graphql course if
you're interested but with this in place
we now have enough to actually use this
variable down below as the argument
value so right here instead of a static
string it is dollar sign slug we run it
and we get our react data
so this is exactly what we need to do
from our component file we can get
started by grabbing this entire query
and copying it to the clipboard then
over in visual studio code we can focus
on getting this set up the first thing
we need to do is import something from
gatsby right here i'm going to import
graphql from gatsby now in the past we
would have also imported use static
query but our template files work a bit
differently
instead of calling use static query we
will instead define our query separately
and export it and the reason for this is
that currently there's no way to access
the context which contains our slug if
we were to work with use static query so
this alternative approach is going to
work really well just for our template
files and this is the only one
so right here we're going to create a
new constant called query
and we're going to set this equal to
right here we'll use graphql along with
a new template string like we've done
before
and then we're just going to paste the
entire query in
now by default it's getting reformatted
and that's okay it just put all of our
arguments and variable definitions on a
single line
down below we're still grabbing the
title
in addition i'm going to grab the date
from front matter and just outside of
front matter i want to grab the html for
the post as well now to ensure that
gatsby can actually access this query
and run it we need to export query as a
named export by just tossing export
right up front
so gatsby's going to grab this graphql
query it's going to run it now the
variable slug is going to come from the
context we set up when we created the
page
then it's going to take the response all
of the post data and it's going to
provide that as a prop to our component
down below
so we're actually all done up above and
down here we can set up our props and
start to use them the first thing i'm
going to put inside of layout is an h1
we are going to render the title right
inside of there
now here's the structure for that
right here it's props dot data this
contains the response so that means on
there we have a markdown remark property
let's grab that
and once we have that we can grab front
matter and title and there we go that's
all we need to get our header rendered
to the screen
now let's actually test things out by
heading over to the browser and right
here i see the great gatsby bootcamp
which is excellent
so next up we have our paragraph i'm
going to use the paragraph to render the
date that's props dot data dot markdown
remark dot front matter dot date
i'm going to render that to the screen
and make sure it shows up right here we
have it which is great
and then from there we'll continue on
with the last thing which is going to be
a container a div
now we already have access to the html
and to render an html string inside of a
component we set up a div and we use the
following prop it's called dangerously
set inner html i type da and i see it
showing up in the auto completion
options
this is the one we need to use in order
to set our markup from an html string
now right here we provide as that prop
value and object so inside of curly
braces i set up a another set of curly
braces for the object itself
and the property is underscore
underscore html we set this equal to the
html string we want to render in our
case that's props.data
dot markdown remark dot
html and we're done
now if we actually save things we can
check it out over in the browser and
what do we get we get our post we have a
paragraph for our text we have a header
for the header we created in markdown
and we have a nice list down below for
the list we set up
so there we go we have our complete blog
structure i have the blog page with the
list of all of our posts i can click one
to go over to that post i could then go
back to the blog and click on another
one
now that we have the basics of a gatsby
markdown blog in place there's just one
other feature i want to add to our
markdown blog which is the ability to
set up images in our posts once we're
done with that which is the topic of the
next video we'll start to focus on
sourcing our content from a cms i'm
excited to continue on with the bootcamp
so let's explore how we can work with
images in our posts
now that we have post content rendered
on our site what i want to focus on in
this video are two final things before
we move on to sourcing our content from
the contentful cms
we're gonna focus on adding support for
images in our posts and we're gonna add
a few final styles to make the post and
the post list look a little nicer than
they currently do
but to get started what i want to do is
figure out how we can add images into
our posts and this is really going to
require us to just install and configure
three new gatsby plugins
now before we get to any of that we need
an image to actually put in one of our
posts you're more than welcome to use
any image you already have if you want
to use the image i'm going to use
you can head over to
links.meade.io
forward slash grass
pick when you visit that url it'll
redirect you over to this picture of
some grass and we're going to save this
image to the project so i'll right click
save image as
on the desktop i have my gatsby bootcamp
folder and there we have the source
posts directory and for the moment i'm
just going to put this file right
alongside of my two markdown files
so let's save that file in its place
i can close that tab
and over in visual studio code we can
make sure it's actually showing up
inside of posts we have grass.png
and right here we have our image
now we want to render that image in one
of our posts and i'm going to put it in
the gatsby bootcamp post i'll put it
right here just below that paragraph
text and just above the topics covered
list
now to add a image to markdown we use
the following syntax it's an exclamation
mark followed by a pair of brackets
followed by a pair of parentheses
in the parentheses we put the path to
the image in this case we're going to
have a relative path from this file to
the image they're in the same directory
so that would be dot forward slash grass
dot png
then we can set up our alt text for when
we're unable to load the image or for
when someone's using an accessibility
device like a screen reader we can just
use grass for that
so with this in place we now have the
finished markdown post and before we
actually install and configure those
three plugins i talked about let's just
see what we get in the browser right
here we get our alt text
so by default gatsby doesn't know where
you're trying to fetch the image from
what we need to do is install and
configure those three plugins to set up
support for this sort of syntax
right inside of our blog posts
so to get started in the terminal down
below what i'm going to do is shut down
the dev server use clear to clear the
terminal output
and we're going to run npm install now
the first plugin we're going to install
is gatsby plugin sharp and this plugin
allows us to use the sharp library
inside of our gatsby site the sharp
library provides all sorts of tools for
working with and processing images and
it's a dependency of the other plugins
we're going to use so this needs to get
installed at the latest version 2.0.32
next up that is gatsby hyphen remark
hyphen images and this is what's going
to allow us to use images inside of our
markdown posts when they're processed
with remark
right here the version for this one at
3.0.10
and the final one we're going to install
is gatsby
remark
relative
images
this is going to allow us to source
images relative to the markdown file so
in this case dot forward slash grass dot
png is going to correctly render the
image right here and the version for
this one at 0.2.2
now we can go ahead and install all
three of those and while that's running
in the background we can head over to
our gatsby config file as we're going to
need to make some pretty big changes to
the plugins array
now the first plugin we're going to set
up is the sharp plugin and that's going
to go right here before we transform our
markdown files so right here that would
be the following gatsby
plug-in sharp now no options are
required for this which is why i'm
providing it as a string as opposed to
an object up above
now the other two plug-ins we installed
are both remark specific we installed
gatsby remark images and gatsby remark
relative images
both of those actually get configured in
the options object for this plugin
that means we need to remove it from
just being a string
and switch it over to being an object
and resolve resolves that same plug-in
value so at this point what have we done
we haven't added any new functionality
but now we do have a structure where we
can set up options since it's an object
and not just a string and that's exactly
what we're going to do
so right here we're setting up an
options object and on this options
object we're setting up a plugins array
so these are plugins specific to the
remark transformer and this is all
outlined in the docs for those specific
plugins so if you're wondering how i
knew the documentation can guide you in
terms of how to configure things
now right here what we need to do is set
up both of those plugins like we would
do with our main plugins array so the
first one is just going to be a string
as no options are required that is
gatsby
remark
relative images
and the second one that's going to be an
object as there are some options we want
to provide so right here
resolve
this is gatsby
remark
images and we're going to provide an
options object just down below
now there are only two options i want to
provide and the first is max with so
let's say i have an image that's 1920 by
1080 a standard hd size the problem is
that i use css in my blog making sure
that the blog width never gets past 750
pixels wide so that image is
unnecessarily large for the context in
which it's going to be used we can have
our gatsby site automatically resize it
using sharp and our other plugins by
setting max width equal to a value in
this case i'll use 750.
next up i'm going to customize link
images to original this is another
option we have available and i'm going
to turn this off otherwise when you
click an image in the post it brings you
over to the actual location of that
image and that's not really behavior i
ever enjoy when i'm reading a blog so i
don't want it for mine
and then we are done so we've configured
our gatsby site to use sharp and then
when we transform our markdown files we
have a couple of other plugins that make
sure the images get rendered correctly
now all we need to do is start up our
server once again with npm run develop
that's going to start up the dev server
it's going to get the image and it's
going to make sure it actually gets
included in the static site
right here let's just refresh things
over in the browser
and what do we get down below we get the
great gatsby boot camp we have our date
and then we have the post content the
paragraph up above our nice grass image
and topics covered down below
so now when we have those plugins in
place we can add images to any of our
posts by simply specifying them like we
did here
now one thing you can additionally do is
organize your posts directory further
let's say that grass is specifically for
the gatsby post it could get a little
confusing if i have dozens of images
inside of here
one thing i could do is create a folder
for each post
something like gatsby for the gatsby
post then i could move the markdown file
and the image right inside of there i
could even take this further creating an
images directory inside of there if i
wanted to but in this case now it's a
little more organized i can see the
assets for the gatsby post right there
and for the react post down below
so with this in place our site should be
working once again we have the exact
same url structure and functionality all
we've done is we've organized that posts
directory just a little bit more
now let's wrap this video up by adding a
few styles into the mix one thing i want
to do for the post page is add more
space between the bottom of the post and
the footer down below as the footer kind
of looks like it could just be some
content for the post
so to do this we're going to work with
css modules i'm going to start by
closing down all open editors
and we want to focus on the components
directory we have our footer component
there is no css module for that so i'll
create it a new file in the components
directory footer dot module dot scss
and from there all we're gonna do is set
up a single class selector for footer
and i'm going to set margin top equal to
3 rem which is the same spacing i use on
the bottom of the header
now we can import this and apply it to
the footer element right here
so
i'll import
footer styles
from
dot forward slash footer dot module dot
s css
then we just set up our class name down
below like we did when we originally
learned about css modules that is footer
styles dot footer and we're done
if we save things we should see a little
more space between the bottom of the
post and the footer that looks a lot
nicer now another major problem is on
the blog list page itself we want to
make sure that this content is clickable
but now it looks terrible and we still
have the numbers we want to clean this
up and we're going to do that by adding
a few more styles into the mix
now this content comes from the pages
directory
in there we have
blog.js
so i'll close the components folder and
the two files we were just working with
we're gonna open up blog.js and we're
going to create styles specifically for
it
right here
i'll create a new file
blog.module.scss
and now we can actually set up some
styles for it we're going to style the
entire list itself and the individual
list items let's start by styling the
list itself i'll set up a class selector
for something like posts
then we'll set up a few styles i'll
start with list style type setting that
equal to none we don't actually want to
show those numbers next to each post and
i'm also going to set margin equal to
zero to remove the default margin that
those lists usually have let's start
there in the blog component we have to
import those styles so i'll import
blog styles from dot forward slash blog
dot module dot s css
and once the import statement is in
place down below will use it now i
designed that for our ordered list right
here
so class name
setting that equal to
here it is blog styles dot posts
now with this in place we should be
headed in the right direction over here
at least we no longer have the numbers
and everything is nice and aligned
now we want to target the individual
items when it comes to the dom structure
it's pretty complex well it's not pretty
complex but it could be we have the list
item we have our link which just gets
converted to an anchor element and in
there we have h2 and p
now in the end of the day i actually
want to apply styles to all four of
these things and there are two
approaches to that
i could set up four new class selectors
over here and i could load for in and
set up four instances of class name or i
could just use one so let's explore how
we might get that done
right here
that is dot post
and this is going to apply some general
styles and all we're going to do here is
put some spacing between our posts above
and below them so margin
1 rem on the top and the bottom and then
zero on the left and the right
now this particular class is going to
get set up on the list item this
represents the individual post so right
here
class name
setting that equal to that's going to be
blog styles.post
now what we're going to do is just use
some basic principles from css and scss
to style the rest by element name this
is perfectly valid and it's a common
approach
so right here i could say something like
let's target our anchor elements inside
of posts and apply some styles to those
maybe for example i want to set the
background equal to a off-white i'll use
the hex code f4 f4 f4 for that and i
don't want that purple and blue link
text so i'll set the color equal to
black which is the hex code the number
zero six times so if we just set that up
we should see those styles actually
applied and over here they are so we
don't have to just use class selectors
in our modules
sometimes we want to set up one and just
style some stuff inside of it making our
lives a lot easier this is also just
fine
now we're going to add a few more styles
inside of here i'll set display equal to
block so we can control the spacing
i'm also going to set padding equal to 1
rem to put some space between the text
and the edge of this off-white box
and from there i'm going to set text
decoration for the link equal to none i
don't want to have that underlined link
and over here we can see we're now
headed in a nice direction
now when we're working with css modules
and using this approach we're not
limited in any way i could still set up
something like this i could target
anchor elements using the hover sudo
class so when you're hovering over the
link we could make the background a
little darker here i'll set the
background equal to
that would be a hex code of e4 e4 e4
which is just a slightly darker gray
this is going to apply exactly like we
would expect as we hover over we see it
now from here we can continue styling
the other elements inside of the post
like the h2 and our paragraph so let's
add those into the mix as well nothing
to stop us from just targeting them by
elements right here
i'm going to set up margin bottom for
the h2 removing that
and then i'm going to set up some styles
for that paragraph as well and then
we'll be done right here just three
styles first up is the color i'm going
to use the hex code with the number
seven six times which is a slightly dark
gray not too dark not too light
then we're going to set the font size
equal to 0.8 rem a little smaller than
it currently is currently it's sitting
at one rem
then we're going to set the font style
equal to italic just to differentiate it
from the other content in that box and
there we go we set up a single class
selector in our css module and we
targeted the elements inside using
element selectors now if we check things
out over here what do we get we have our
styled blog list i can still access
those posts by clicking on them i can
view the post content and everything is
looking pretty good so now we have a
complete site with a markdown blog all
powered by gatsby we could take this and
we could continue on with it really
making it our own for either ourselves
or for a company we're working with now
this is just the start being able to
create a markdown blog is awesome and it
works really well for a lot of folks who
prefer that but with gatsby we can also
source our content from a cms and that
is exactly what we're going to cover
next i'm excited to get to that so let's
jump in to the next
lessons in this video we're going to
start the process of connecting our
gatsby project to a content management
system now in this boot camp we'll be
working with the contentful cms but the
exact same principles would apply if you
wanted to use another content management
system like wordpress or drupal gatsby
has plugins to support all of those cmss
and more but once again we're going to
end up using contentful it's my personal
favorite of those options it's really
easy to work with and we can get started
for free
you can find it over at contentful.com
and right here we're just gonna go ahead
and create a free account everything
we're going to do in this boot camp is
completely free and doesn't require a
credit card just a free account
so let's create that account and once we
have it created we'll get some content
into the mix right here i'm going to
create a new account with you so i see
the exact same stuff that you're seeing
so let's fill out those basic account
details
when it comes to choose your development
platform we're just going to pick
javascript though honestly this choice
doesn't matter and down below we'll toss
a password into the mix
now we can go ahead and actually create
the account and when we do it's gonna
bring us over to a little welcome screen
trying to get us to pick one of the
tutorials to work through over here for
content creators like a copywriter and
over here for developers honestly we're
not going to work through either of
those as we'll be discussing things
together in the video and the quickest
way to get what we want is to just click
explore content modeling this is going
to create an example project for us and
that's not a project we're going to work
with this comes pre-populated with
models and data but what we want to do
is figure out how we can set things up
from scratch for our needs so once the
example project is created we're just
going to create a brand new one and
start there
alright let's explore the example
project and we're done exploring it
let's create our own
from the menu we can click create space
a space is like a new project and we're
gonna go ahead and use our second free
space we get two on a free plan and
right here i'll just call this something
like the great
gatsby boot camp though the name is not
important and right here we want to
create an empty space that we can
populate with our own content in this
case the blog content we want to show in
our gatsby site so let's actually create
this new space right here a confirmation
screen
and once it's created what we need to do
is focus on defining the type of data we
want to track so there are two main tabs
i want to talk about up here we have
content model and we have content
content model allows us to define models
for the content on our site this could
be a model for a blog post where we have
a title a published date and a body it
could be a model for an author where we
have the author's name their twitter
profile link and a profile picture so
over here we're creating structured data
under the content tab we actually create
instances of those things so this is
where we would define our six blog posts
and our two authors and whatever other
content we wanted to create
so let's see this in action
under content model we're going to
create our first content model for a
blog post so right here we have a
required name field i'll just use blog
post and down below it's creating an api
identifier for us which we'll end up
using a bit later there's no need for a
description so we'll leave that blank
although you could come back and edit it
later and now we're just going to create
the model
now the model by default isn't tracking
any data whatsoever it's up to us to
configure the fields that make sense for
a blog post now we already have some
structured data over here in our two
markdown posts for both we have the
title we also have the date and finally
we have the actual post content so those
are three distinct fields and we're
going to be adding three fields to the
blog post content model let's go ahead
and add our very first field right here
we can see that with contentful we have
a lot of field options this could be a
text field a complex rich text field
with formatting images and more it could
be a simple text field it could be a
number date and time location media a
boolean like a check box and a whole
bunch of other options now in our case
we just want a simple text field for the
title so let's pick that and give it a
name right here we type something to
show in the contentful forms in this
case capital t title and behind the
scenes it generates a field id and this
is how we'll access our data from the
graphql api a bit later down below we
have a few options none of which we need
so we can create our first field
let's go ahead and add our second field
and it's actually one i forgot about
this is also going to be a text field
and the name for this one is going to be
slug so there's no longer a file name
that we can use to find the slug so
we're gonna have the post creator pick a
slug for that post
next up is the published date right here
we'll use their date and time field for
this giving in a name like published
date
we'll create that field and from there
there's only one more field we need the
field for the post body and that is
going to be a rich text field so right
here we'll click that option and go
ahead and provide a name right here i'll
use body for this one
now once we create that we've finished
off our content model we have modeled a
blog post with four pieces of data and
as long as those four pieces of data are
provided we have enough to actually get
something rendered to the screen
from here all we need to do is click
save to actually save this content model
and once it's saved we can start to
create blog posts based off of the model
over here for this we go over to the
content tab
and we're going to click add blog post
that option is also available up above
whoops it's not available yet not until
we have our first post in place
so let's get our first post in place
right here add blog post and were
brought to our blog post editor page it
has all of the fields we specified title
slug published date and body and now we
can create our very first post
for the title i'll use a contentful blog
post
for the slug i'll just use something
like contentful i can pick whatever
makes sense for me
then down below i'll say this one was
published today and we can set up our
post body as well
my post is here dot dot dot
now currently this post is not published
which means that even if we did have
things wired up with our gatsby site
this data would not be accessible to the
outside world we can fix that by
changing the status from draft to
published by clicking our publish button
now we have our first published post and
if we head back over to the content page
we can see it showing up right here
from here we can add a second post into
the mix then we'll figure out how to
actually pull this data into our site
right here something like debugging
nodejs
i'll have the slug be debug
hyphen node
for the published date i'll say this was
published a couple of days ago
and for the body i will say here's
how you can debug your apps dot dot dot
and we'll go ahead and publish this one
as well
so now we have our very first content
model blog post and we've created two
instances of it a contentful blog post
and debugging nodejs
from here what we want to do is figure
out how we can access this data via our
gatsby graphql api once we have that in
place we'll be actually able to show
this content on the site
getting that done requires us to set up
a gatsby plugin so let's head over to
the gatsby site go to the plugins page
and we'll be searching for contentful
now right here the first result that's
the one we're looking for gatsby source
contentful that's going to allow us to
source our graphql content directly from
the contentful cms
now actually setting this up is really
easy down below all we need to do is
provide our space id which is the id for
our project and our private access token
and we'll look at where that lives in
just a moment now before we actually set
this up i did want to mention there are
source plugins for other cms's as well
for example if i search wordpress we can
find one for that gatsby source
wordpress and if i search for something
else like drupal there are plugins for
that as well so when it comes to your
gatsby site you can source that content
from a lot of different places you could
even use multiple if that made sense for
your particular situation
in this case though we are going to set
up that contentful source plugin so
let's head over to visual studio code
shut down things in the terminal and
we're going to run npm install to get
that installed that is gatsby
source contentful
and we're going to go ahead and install
that and we can go through the process
of setting it up in the meantime so to
get this set up what we need to do is
head over to that gatsby node file
excuse me the gatsby config file where
we have our long list of plugins and
we're going to add a new one into the
mix now we could put this wherever we'd
like i'm just going to toss it right up
top as the first item in the plugins
array
right here this is something we'll be
setting up options for so this one needs
to be an object in there setting up the
resolve property with the plugin name
right here that's gatsby
source contentful and i can see down
below that it did indeed install
correctly which is a great first step
next up we provide our options object
and on the options object we have to
specify two things our space id
that's a string and we also need to
specify our access token that is also a
string this is what's going to allow us
to actually fetch that content now both
of these we can find over in the
contentful web app so let's head over
there
from here we can go to settings
and down to api keys now your spaces by
default have an example key pair set up
for you so if we click on that we can
view all of those details down below
down here we have our space id and we
also have our content delivery api
access token that is what we need
so to set this up we're going to use
environment variables to prevent the
sensitive data from sneaking into our
source code we already have an
environment variable file for that so
we'll just make some more changes to the
dev env file right here we have our one
environment variable let's add two more
first up will be contentful underscore
space underscore id
then after that we'll have contentful
access
token and all we need to do is populate
those two with the correct values i'll
grab the space id
i'll bring that right here
then i'll grab that content delivery
access token and i'll bring that over to
the env file as well
now with this in place we can access
those two things in our config file and
then we'll be all done we'll have access
to all of that contentful data let's go
ahead and use those variables so over
here for space id that is process dot
env dot contentful
space
id
and down below for access token that is
process dot env dot contentful
access
token and we're all done everything is
configured so with this what seven lines
of configuration code we're able to set
up everything we need to source content
from contentful now what we're going to
do is start up our app in development
mode using npm run develop and once
that's up and running we're gonna head
over to graphql playground and take a
look at the new queries we have access
to
because those queries are going to allow
us to access the data we just created so
right here these sites starting up i'm
gonna head over to graphql playground
and give things a quick refresh and over
in the docs we should see those new
queries showing up and right here we
have six now we have two for working
with content types this is not going to
allow us to fetch the content itself but
it's a way to work with content types
not something we need and we also have a
couple for working with our rich text
node as there's some specifics to that
we'll talk about shortly for now what i
really want to focus on is contentful
blog post and all contentful blog post
we can use the first one to fetch data
about an individual post and we can use
the second one to fetch a list of all
posts and that's exactly what we're
going to end up doing now if i crack
that open we can see a similar structure
to what we had with our other queries we
have edges we have node and node
represents our post we have title slug
published date and body
so let's actually set up a query to
fetch some post data i'm going to crack
open a new tab over here we'll set up a
brand new query and this query is going
to use all
contentful blog post to fetch something
about every single post we're working
with
now we want to work with edges
and there we have node and all we're
going to do is grab the title for each
and every post so if i take a quick
moment to fire that off what do i get i
get debugging node.js
and i get a contentful blog post so
there we go we've successfully sourced
the content from the cms right inside of
our gatsby graphql api let's grab a
couple of other fields real quick as
well we're going to grab the slug for
each post and we're also going to grab
the published date now i'm intentionally
not grabbing the body field because it's
not as simple as just getting a body
back which is a bunch of html there's a
little more to it and don't worry we're
going to address that in the next video
for now though we can fire off our new
query and we get new data i see the
correct slug and the published date for
both of my posts we're also going to
talk about how we can sort our posts
from most recently published to oldest
and we'll figure out how we can actually
format this date to be a little more
friendly when it comes to rendering it
to the screen i'm excited to continue on
with contentful but let's take a quick
moment to recap what we did essentially
we use contentful as a web app to manage
our site content we have our content
models and our individual content
themselves we were then able to pull all
of this into our gatsby graphql api
using another one of gatsby's source
plugins in this case it was gatsby
source contentful now that we have
access to it via our api we could use
those queries in our react components to
get that data rendered to the screen
that's the topic of the next lesson so
let's jump right in
now that you have content in your
contentful cms what we're gonna do is
figure out how we can get it rendered in
the browser we've already seen a sample
graphql query that fetches our blog
posts from contentful and the goal in
this video is to get our post list
rendered using contentful posts instead
of using the posts we created with
markdown files
so to kick things off what i want to do
is talk about how we can customize the
all contentful blog post query we're
going to learn how we can sort our posts
in a particular order and how we can
customize the response of things like
published date getting a date that's a
little more user friendly as opposed to
the current time stamp we're seeing in
the response
let's get started by figuring out how to
sort our data and remember graphql is
self-documenting so the docs contain
everything we need in order to get this
done
down below we have all contentful blog
posts the query we're using here we have
our type details that's the response
we're looking for the arguments allowing
us to customize the response there are
four we have skip and limit which is
useful for pagination we have filter
which is useful if you're trying to
implement something like a search bar
and you want to filter to a subset of
your posts and we have sort sort allows
us to sort our data in an order that
makes sense now right here when we use
sort we provide two pieces of
information we provide the field we want
to search by excuse me sort by and we
also provide the order either ascending
or descending so right here for fields
we can see we have a bunch of different
fields available now this allows us to
sort by various fields that aren't
applicable to what we're working with
right here we have a lot of different
fields because of that special rich text
field we set up in our case if we scroll
up a little bit the one we're looking
for is just sorting by published date
and that's exactly what we're going to
do so let's take this over to the query
right here on the query we are going to
set up our arguments
i'm going to set up sort
and remember we have to provide fields
that's plural and the field we're
working with here is going to be the
following that is published date
then next up we have to provide an order
and in this case we could sort in
ascending with asc or descending with d
e s c and this is the order we're going
to go with we'll have the most recent
posts first and we'll have the oldest
ones at the bottom
so if i run this we should see the order
reversed as this was published on the
8th and this was published on the 10th
and right here that's exactly what
happens so we have our newer content
first using this argument
one more thing we can do is customize
the published date value
so let's check this out if we head over
to the docs once again we're going to go
all the way to the left and we're going
to go to the type details
we have edges
we have node and here is the node we're
currently working with we have title
slug and published date and you'll
notice that with published date we have
a parentheses set right here if we click
on that there are actually arguments we
can provide for just this one field to
customize it i could do something like
from now to say this post was published
three days ago or 10 seconds ago
i could use format string in order to
customize exactly how i wanted to format
it let's explore both we'll start with
from now
so right here
set up some parentheses
from now
setting that to true
i run it and i can see a day ago and
three days ago so maybe that's what we
want in which case this would work
really well
if we wanted to customize it even
further what we could do is use the
following it is format string
now this uses the formatting pattern
made popular by the moment js library so
here's an example
i will use the following pattern it is
four m's followed by a space
capital d
lowercase o
comma
then
y four times that's month day and year
and if i run it we can see we get the
following setup april 10th 2019 april
8th
2019.
now you can provide whatever you'd like
in there to really customize it and make
it your own if you want to find all of
the patterns you can use you can open up
a new tab and go to moment js dot com
forward slash docs once you're there on
the right hand side you want to go to
display and down below you can see all
of the different tokens you can use in
your pattern so there are different ways
to represent months the day of the month
the day of the week there's all sorts of
great patterns here allowing you to
generate the specific output you want in
our case though we're not going to go
any further we're going to leave it like
this april 10th 2019 is exactly what i
want to show on the screen
so now that we have this query in place
we're going to take this over to our
blog page and we're going to render
these posts instead of the markdown
posts
now getting that done is actually going
to be your challenge for the video so
let's dive right into that in visual
studio code we're going to close all of
the open files we have and we're going
to focus on just one inside of our pages
directory we have blog.js
now currently we have a query that
fetches the markdown data and renders
that down below we need to change both
of these things to work with the
contentful data so up above i'm going to
paste in the challenge comments and
they're pretty straightforward the goal
is to render the contentful posts in our
list
so first up you want to swap out the
markdown query with the contentful query
and if you want to customize it further
using other arguments or options you're
more than welcome to but in general this
query can be used inside of the
component
next up you have to update the component
to render the new data so our data
structure is a little bit different even
though we still have those same three
things we still have the title the date
and the slug they're just in a different
place on the response
and for the moment don't worry that your
link is gonna link to a non-existent
page we'll address that shortly finally
test your work pull up the blog page and
make sure you see your two contentful
posts showing up as opposed to the two
markdown posts
all right pause the video knock that out
test your work and when you're done come
back and click play
how'd that go let's get started and the
first thing we're going to do is swap
out the queries now we have the old
query over here so let's go ahead and
get rid of that it's no longer all
markdown remark we're going to go ahead
and work on the new one so that is all
contentful blog post
from there we're still going to be
setting up our arguments now we could do
all of that on one line or we could
break it out onto multiple if we wanted
to do it on one line it would look like
this we'll set sort equal to an object
on there fields is equal to published
date
and then we'll go ahead and set order
equal to descending perfect
next up we have to go ahead and specify
what exactly we want back on the
response that is edges
node and from there we need the title
we also need the slug and finally we
need our published date and we're going
to format that exactly like we did over
here using format string
so right here that would be format
string setting it equal to whatever
format string we wanted to use and i'll
use the same one from before the full
month followed by the day of the month a
comma then the full year all right now
that we have this in place we are done
with step number one and at this point
our program would crash if we tried to
run things that's because we're trying
to access data down below that no longer
exists since we've changed the query up
above
in the browser if i go over to the blog
page it is indeed failing as expected
so now that we've seen things fail let's
actually get things working we can go
ahead and move on to step number two
where we update the component to render
the new data so right down here let's
knock that out
data dot all markdown remark that no
longer exists it is all
contentful blog post now we still have
edges and we still want to map over that
down below here we have our list item
what we need to do is customize this
starting with the slug it is still edge
node but there's no longer fields it's
just edge node slug exactly like we're
seeing up above edge node slug
down below we have the title as well
that does not exist on front matter it's
right on node and below that we have the
old date front matter that no longer
exists and it's called something
different right here
edge.node.publisheddate
perfect now with this in place we have
the new query and we're rendering that
brand new data and hopefully everything
works as expected when we actually move
on to step number three and test our
work so i'll refresh the page over in
the site and what do i get i have my two
blog posts a contentful blog post and
debugging node.js now i can see down
below at the bottom left in the little
gray bar that it is linking over to the
correct pages but if i click those links
obviously we don't get the pages content
since we haven't wired that part up but
the blog list itself is indeed working
and that is a great start
with this in place we're all done for
the moment in the next video we're going
to go ahead and actually create those
pages dynamically using the contentful
content i'm excited to get to that so
let's jump right in to the next one
now that your list of blog posts is
populated from contentful we want to
make sure we're generating pages for
each of those posts right now if we
click on them we get nothing and that's
a problem so in this video we're going
to accomplish two things first we need
to dynamically create new pages for the
contentful posts and then two we need to
make sure we're actually rendering the
post content in the post page template
so that template is going to need to
change a little bit
the entire focus is going to be on
gatsby node where we dynamically create
our pages and the blog template where we
render the content to the screen
let's get started with gatsby node now
to set things up for markdown it
required us to use two of the internal
apis on create node and create pages
now oncreate node was just used to
generate slugs for our posts that's a
field we set up in contentful so we
actually don't need this anymore we can
remove it entirely down below the only
one we're going to use is create pages
we just need to adjust it instead of
fetching the markdown slugs and using
those to create pages we want to fetch
our contentful slugs and use them
so let's get started right here we have
all markdown remark i'm going to remove
all of that we still have our base query
though this time we'll use all
contentful blog post like we've used
before
there are no arguments required as we
just need a list of slugs there's no
need to order it as that doesn't matter
right here
edges
node
and the only thing we're going to grab
is the slug as that's the only thing we
need
now down below when we loop through the
data we can use the contentful slug
right here
dot response.data that still exists no
longer do we have all markdown remark we
now have all
contentful
blog post we still have edges and we
still want to iterate over that using
four each inside we have the create page
call
the component is still blog template the
path is still forward slash blog forward
slash the slug but remember the slug no
longer lives on fields it is just edge
dot node dot slug down below for context
we have to make the same adjustment
removing fields and one of those extra
dots and there we go that is it so when
we're working with a cms there's a lot
less for us to do behind the scenes to
get things to work we removed a lot of
code and now we're actually going to
have pages for our contentful posts
before we worry about restarting the
server let's head over to the blog
template and pull in the new data so we
still want to set up a query though it's
going to look a little different than
this one so i'm going to comment out
this one and we'll build up the new
query from scratch
down below we also have our blog
component everything in here is gonna be
similar though different enough where
we're just going to start from scratch
with this as well
so now blog just renders an empty page
using the layout component let's make
sure that we're at least seeing that
page instead of the 404 page so in the
terminal down below i'm going to restart
things since we have made changes to the
gatsby node file and once the server is
up and running if i refresh this url i
would expect to see something valid as a
page should exist with this slug from
contentful right here i give things a
refresh and this is a great first step
we're no longer seeing that 404 page
now let's set up our query once again to
fetch the contentful data so we can
actually render some stuff to the blog
page now it's gonna look similar to what
we have up above though obviously
slightly different we'll start off the
same exporting a new constant called
query all of which is required in order
for the gatsby parser to find your query
and run it
right here graphql
inside of template strings we put our
query
this query is still going to get access
to the slug variable which we need we
need to be able to target the individual
post
and slug is a string just like we had to
find up above
now inside of here which particular
query are we going to use
over inside of graphql playground
we had worked with all contentful blog
posts in the docs there is a way to get
a single blog post using contentful blog
post
so this will allow us to target a
specific post
and if we scroll down to the arguments
we can see there are quite a few
different ways we could target a post i
could target it by its title the slug
the published date the content and
others
in this case we're going to target it by
its slug so we'll be using this slug
argument and in there we'll use eq to
find the slug using equality
all right let's set that up so over here
that's going to be contentful blog post
setting up the argument we just talked
about slug
in there eq and the value would be
whatever is stored on the slug variable
so now we're targeting the correct post
and we can fetch some data for the
moment we're just going to fetch the
title and the published date don't worry
we are going to render the body in this
video but it requires an extra step so
let's get started with the simple stuff
right here
we'll have the title
down below we'll have the published date
which i'll also format using format
string
and i'll provide the same format we had
before i'll start off with the month
then the day of the month and finally
the year
with this in place we should have access
to that data in our component down below
let's get these two pieces of
information rendered we had the title
nh1 header tag and we had the date
inside of a paragraph so right here for
us that would be the following it's
still props.data exactly like what we
had before this time though we have to
go into contentful blog post and in
there we have the title down below let's
do the same thing for the published date
that's
dot
props.data.com
blog post dot published date
and now if we save things we should see
these two pieces of data showing up over
in the browser right here i have the
title and the correct published date for
this post and if i go back to the blog
list and select the other one that data
shows up as well which is a great step
in the right direction
now that we have this in place we want
to focus on getting the post content
itself rendered and as i mentioned it's
not as simple as just grabbing a single
field and then using that field like we
did with the html field that we got with
our markdown query from up above
so let's explore this and to get started
we'll remove that redundant query and
what we're going to do is head over to
graphql playground real quick and take a
look at another property we have access
to
so all we're going to do is modify this
all contentful blog post query we
already have in place
alongside of title slug and published
date we're going to grab body now body
itself is not something we can directly
grab there are fields inside of it we
need to access and in this case when
we're working with a rich text field in
contentful we want to grab jason this
returns a json string which is a
representation of the content in that
rich text field so if we go ahead and
set this up and run our query it's going
to work and we're going to see we get a
lot more data in the response here for
our first post we have body jason and we
can see the value is a complex structure
we have all sorts of different fields
and arrays and objects and somewhere
inside of there we can see the data that
we actually wrote out my post is here
and if we scroll down for the other post
we can see that as well
now the reason they use this complex
structure is to keep track of things
like the paragraphs embedded assets like
images headers bold text italics and
more all of that is mapped out in this
object now the good news is that we
don't need to manually parse this and
figure out how to render things to the
screen contentful actually provides an
npm library we can install and it's
going to take the json and it's going to
convert it into a set of react
components that we can render anywhere
so it's not just specific to javascript
the library is actually specific to
react which makes it really easy to work
with
so let's install this library and set it
up it'll be as simple as a function call
right here we need to shut down the
server and i'll clear the output and
we're going to install this library
that's npmi
it is at contentful
forward slash rich
text
react renderer so this is going to allow
us to render rich text fields using
react it provides a single function
we're going to import it and call it and
that's going to allow us to get our rich
text field shown on the screen let's run
the installation and while that's
running up above we can focus on our
import statement so we're going to grab
a single thing from that library it is a
function
and it's called document
to
react components
now this is going to take in the json
that we're grabbing from the api once we
set that up over here and it's going to
spit out react components that we can
render wherever we want to
now we're going to grab that from the
library we just installed contentful
rich text react renderer
perfect now that we have this in place
let's actually use it and it could not
be easier to work with so first up we do
have to grab the data so that's body
grabbing the json value and we use this
down below now what i'm going to do is
set up right after the paragraph a set
of curly braces so we can set up our
function call we're going to call
document
to react components
exactly like we imported up above and
all we do is we pass in that document
that jason data so for us that is props
dot data dot contentful blog post
whoops
got a little ahead of myself with the
keys there
and on here we want to access body and
we want to access jason with this line
in place we now should be able to see
our post content on the screen right
here let's restart the server with npm
run develop we're going to check out
that content then we're going to make
more complex changes to the content in
contentful and check those out as well
right here things are starting up so
i'll refresh my site and once we get the
blog post page we can pick a post and we
do see the content in a paragraph which
is awesome i have the content for the
first post and for the second one
now let's head over to contentful and
add some more complexity to those posts
so we can see what we get down below in
the body let's add some more stuff below
our text i'll add a header
a new section and below that i'll add
some more text i love gatsby with
contentful
and i'll go ahead and make gatsby bold
because i can and now we're actually
going to add an image into the mix as
well
so right here we can link an image using
this plus button we can link an asset
now we haven't added any images to
contentful we can do that in two ways
one we could go to the media tab and add
them there then link them or we could
just add it right here when we try to
link it so there are no assets we
haven't added any from the media tab we
could just create one on the fly so i'll
click that button
and here we just need to pick a title
for this one i'll call this grass
we have a description and we have the
actual file down below in this case for
the file what i'm going to do is pick
grass from my machine which we
downloaded earlier so i have that in my
project that is gatsby boot camp
source here we have posts
gatsby
grass.png this is the one we had used in
our markdown posts now we're going to
use it in our contentful post
so once we have things loaded in we can
publish this asset
once the asset is published we can use
the back button to pick it from the list
and right here we can see it's already
been put inside of our post
so i'll remove the extra little space
down below and now we have a little more
complexity i have some text a header an
image and some more text down there
let's publish these changes and check
things out over in the browser what i'm
going to do is shut down the server and
start it up once again so it can fetch
that new contentful data
and then we'll just re-render excuse me
refresh the post page to check things
out so right over here we want to go to
the other post a contentful blog post
i'll give things a refresh and what do
we get we get some of our new content i
have a header which looks styled
consistent with the rest of the site and
i have my other paragraph with the bold
text down below
the only thing i'm missing is my image
by default your images are not going to
show up but the good news is that we can
make a small change to how we're calling
that document to react components
function to actually render those images
right in line before we focus on
changing the code let's look at the new
data for our complex post so right here
i'm going to rerun the same query we had
before where we grab that json and we
can see that it's a lot longer than what
we had in the past we have our initial
paragraph with the text here
then down below we have our heading 2
with that text a new section and below
that we have a very long and very
complex object for the asset the image
that we've embedded in that post
if we scroll down there's a lot of stuff
we just don't care about and are not
going to use
but we can scan for two things one is
the title right here grass we're going
to use that as the alt text for the
image and then down below that we have
the url this is what we're going to use
to actually fetch and render that image
now this object can be really
overwhelming as there's just a whole
bunch of stuff we don't need to worry
about almost any of it all we're going
to do is drill into that object to grab
those two values and we're going to
generate an image element like we would
do in any other situation
so let's leave the actual rendered post
up in the background and over here we're
going to focus on drilling down to that
data
right here to do that we have to set up
an optional options object so a new
constant options is going to be an
object and we pass that in as the second
argument to that function the document
to react components function
so i'm going to pass that in
now what we can do is customize how
certain node types are rendered on here
we start by setting up the render node
property this allows us to override how
specific nodes are rendered and we saw
various node types in that data for
example we saw things like paragraph and
heading 2 we set that up as the property
saying that's the type we want to
customize
in our case the type we want to
customize has a hyphen in it so i have
to wrap that name inside of quotes that
is embedded
asset
block and all we do is provide as the
value a function to run we're
customizing how the node is rendered we
get the node data passed in and we
return some jsx in this case all we're
going to do is return an image
now we want to set up values for the alt
text and for source so let's start to
get that done right here i'm going to
create standalone variables for both of
those things so it's a little easier to
work with
we'll have alt
then i'll have url down below and both
of these are going to get applied on to
the image
alt will get its value from the alt
variable
then when we set up the source for the
image the value will come from url
now in order to get the correct values
we need to drill into the node which is
that really big complex object so let's
check that out in graphql playground
over here we have our complex object
there's quite a bit to it we have the
data we want and then we have a bunch of
other stuff we just don't care about
now our node is this object right here
it starts with the data property we have
data.target
now we also have cis which we're going
to collapse and when we collapse that
we'll see the two fields we're looking
for so this object is the node which
means we need node data target fields
title enus for the alt text
and then on fields we need file en us
url for the url now it's never fun to
drill into a complex object like this
but that's just where our data lives and
it's going to be necessary just a single
time
so let's get that done over here we'll
start with the alt text that's
node.data.target
from there it was fields
dot title and we're grabbing the title
in the locale i have en us if you see a
different locale over in graphql
playground you want to go ahead and use
that and then down below we're going to
grab url
this is going to be node
dot data
dot target dot fields here it was file
followed by the locale en us
followed by url
now we should be able to see both of
those things showing up in the image
element and the end result should be a
rendered image in the browser and that
is exactly what we're getting right here
we have all of our post content showing
up including the image and all of this
is managed from contentful so when we're
working with contentful we can easily
manage our content or someone else who
owns the site can manage the content
using this nice interface and behind the
scenes they don't need to worry about
changing code or changing markdown files
or changing anything else
now once again contentful contentful's
not for everybody and neither is
markdown it's really up to you to pick
what makes the most sense for you and
run with that alright that's it for this
one let's continue on and the boot camp
is almost done there are just a couple
of things that i didn't get a chance to
cover so far that i want to cover in the
next lesson or two so let's get started
there are just two videos left in this
one you're gonna learn how to set up a
404 page and you're also going to learn
how to customize the head of your
document to set up things like a page
title and then in the next lesson the
final one we'll take our gatsby site and
we'll deploy it live to the web for now
though let's get started setting up a
404 page and this process could not be
easier in visual studio code i'm going
to close all open editors and all we
need to do
is create a new page in the pages
directory and this file should be called
404.js
in here we export a react component and
that is what renders when someone visits
a page that's not found so let's
actually get to this
right here i'm going to start by
importing react since we'll be setting
up a react component and down below i'll
create it const not found equals i'll
use a new functional component returning
some jsx
and then down below we can export it so
export
default not found
now on the not found page i still want
to render the layout so people can use
the navigation bar to go over to a page
that does exist and i'm also going to
link to a different page like the home
page in the not found text so right here
i'll import link
from gatsby
and then down below i'll import the
layout component that we created from
that file that is dot dot forward slash
components forward slash layout
now we can actually fill out the return
value for our functional component and
we're going to start by rendering the
layout let's set the layout up and
inside of there we will render a couple
of custom things on the page as well
i'll start with a header something like
page not found should get the message
across
then down below i'll set up a paragraph
and in there all i'm going to do is use
the link component
and i'm going to link them over to a
page that i know does exist i'll say
something like head home
and this link will go to
forward slash and there we go that's all
we need to do to get a 404 page setup
with our gatsby projects let's actually
test this out
so down below i need to start up my
server npm run develop and once that's
up and running we're going to visit a
url that does not exist so right over
here i'll go to my site forward slash
this
is not real and i misspelled it but who
cares that's the whole point
now when we're running our development
server gatsby first brings us to this
page which is designed to give us more
information as we're creating our site
we can see pages that do exist we can
see why we're seeing the 404 in the
production version of the site though
this would never show up now we can view
our actual 404 page by clicking preview
custom 404 page
and when i do that we get what we
designed so this is what a regular user
would see once we actually get our site
up and running in production which once
again is the topic of the next lesson so
right here they can go to a page that
does exist or they can just click that
home link to get back to a working page
so there we go the 404 is all set up now
i want to focus on customizing the head
of our document so we can set up things
like page titles and to get that done
we'll be using the very popular react
library called helmet if you're not
familiar with it it's pretty much the
standard for working with the head of
your document from react and there's a
gatsby plugin that's going to help us
integrate that into our sites let's head
over to the plugins page on the gatsby
site and search for helmet right here
gatsby plug-in react helmet that's the
one we're going to end up using now
there are actually two libraries we'll
install we'll be installing this plug-in
and we'll also be installing the react
helmet library which is linked to right
here we can crack that open in a new tab
to check that out as well this is just a
standalone react component that we could
use outside of a gatsby site it's a
really great choice for managing the
head of your document and they have a
ton of great examples down below as to
how you can get all of this done
now when it comes to the plugin we're
going to install this pulls all of that
information in to the static pages for
our site so it's definitely going to be
an important piece to the puzzle let's
take a quick moment to install both of
these then we'll actually wire them up
in our app
so down below we'll shut things down
i'll use clear to clear the terminal
output npm install first up is gatsby
plug-in react helmet
at the latest version
3.0.12 and next up is react helmet
itself at 5.2.0
now we can go ahead and let these
install and while they're installing we
need to configure this gatsby plugin in
our gatsby config file now there's no
need to provide any options for this one
so it's as simple as listing it out in
our plugins array and i'll add it right
up top as the first plugin right here
gatsby
plug-in
react helmet and there we go it is
configured now what we can do is import
the react helmet component and actually
use it to set up titles for our pages
now there are two ways we could do this
we could manually set up this
configuration in every single page
component as well as our blog template
or we could create a component that
handles the configuration for us
something simple that we can render on
all pages meaning that we only have to
configure react helmet once and of
course that's the approach we're going
to take
so in the components directory let's
create a new file called head.js for the
component that's going to manage the
head of our document right here we're
going to import react
from react and we're also going to
import something from react helmet right
here
it is a named export called helmet that
is a react component from the library we
just installed react helmet and we're
done
now we can create our component and
export it from the file so right here
const head equals a functional component
where we're going to return some jsx
which we'll get to in just a second
down below let's export it
export
default head
now when it comes to what this component
should render all we're going to do is
render helmet itself we're not actually
going to add anything else into this
component and when helmet gets rendered
it doesn't show anything on the screen
instead it just manages the head of the
document so right here we can configure
things like the title using the title
prop this is a test
so let's leave our component file like
this don't worry we will grab a proper
title from the site metadata a little
bit later for now though let's just get
this title showing up to do this once
again this component needs to be loaded
in and used in every single one of our
pages including our page templates let's
get started with the most obvious one
the home page then we'll move on to the
other pages we have so right here we
have to import head
import
head
from dot dot forward slash components
forward slash head and then we render it
and we're just going to do that as the
first thing in the layout and remember
it's not going to show anything there
this is just going to allow us to manage
the document head so right here i'll
render our component we can then go
ahead and save things and start up the
development server once again so i'll
use clear followed by npm run develop
and once it's up and running we'll visit
the home page and hopefully we see our
custom title showing up
over here we have the home page i'll
just give things a quick refresh let's
try one more time
there we go the server is finally up and
in a second we should see our page we
have the page and we have our title this
is a test is showing up
now when it comes to customizing that
fob icon all you need to do for that is
swap out the file in the static
directory down below fob icon dot ico
so let's continue on with this
particular example and what i want to do
is focus on actually pulling in useful
information
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to pull in the site metadata
title this is something we're going to
show as part of the title for every
single page it's not the only thing
we're going to show but it's part of
what we're going to show so right here
for a site like gatsby i can see that if
i hover over this title for a second
it's going to show me the full thing we
start off with something specific to
that page gatsby plugin react helmet
followed by a vertical line followed by
the site name gatsby js that's similar
to the approach we're going to take here
so each page will have something
specific to render up there but then
we'll also have something generic like
the site title
to get that done let's first pull in the
site title so right here we're going to
use use static query
i'll import
use
static query and i'll import graphql
from gatsby
then down below we can actually grab
that information so const data equals
we're going to call use static query
using the graphql template tag with our
string and right here we're going to
perform one of the first queries we ever
set up query
site
site meta data in there grabbing the
title so now the title is something we
can actually use down below let's go
ahead and set that up so instead of the
static title
we're going to set up a dynamic one
we have that data at data
dot site
dot site metadata dot title we can save
things and hopefully we now see that
showing up on the home page right over
here i have full stack boot camp so this
is a great start the next thing we want
to be able to do is pass in the part
that's specific to this page which is
going to come first to get that done the
actual component is going to get called
with a single prop so whenever someone
renders ahead they can pass in the title
they want to use for that page so here
i'm using head on the home page so i
could say something like home
now i can go ahead and actually access
that prop in the component and use that
when determining what the title should
be so right over here let's get that
done we have our props passed in i'm
just going to destructure that object to
grab the title and now we can use that
in helmet down below right here we're
going to change the title prop that we
pass to helmet we're still going to
include this information but we're going
to put all of that in a template string
so we'll start off by adding in the page
title that's the title prop up above
then a space the vertical bar and
another space followed by the site title
right here once again
data.site.sitemetadata.title
now we're going to see both of those
things on the homepage so right over
here i have home followed by full stack
bootcamp so now we have a little
component making it really easy to
integrate this into all of our pages
instead of needing to write this code in
every single page let's go ahead and
actually get that done for the four
other pages we have in the pages
directory and we're also going to do the
same thing for the dynamic page template
for blog posts so right here what i'm
going to do is copy the import statement
to grab the head component and we'll
continue on
in the contact page we'll paste that in
we'll set up the head component inside
of layout and right here all we're going
to do is provide the title for this
specific page which will just be contact
next up we have the blog page so we want
to import head
down below we want to use it right here
we have layout i'll go ahead and set
head up
providing the title for this particular
page which will just be blog perfect
next up we have about where we do the
exact same thing
import
and set it up
head
title about and we're done and finally
the new page we just created our 404
page we can also use the head component
inside of here
i'll import it and down below we'll go
ahead and use it setting up the title to
something like 404
perfect
the only other page we need to worry
about as mentioned is the template for
our blog posts
right here what we can actually do is
use the blog post title as the page
title
so i'm going to import head exactly like
we did before and down below we're going
to set it up so right here in layout
we're going to set up head but instead
of providing a static string which made
sense for our other pages we're going to
provide a dynamic value the actual blog
post title which is used just down below
so that's props dot data dot contentful
blog post
dot title and we're done
now we have this set up everywhere on
our site and we can test things out so
over here we go to the blog page we have
blog on about we have about on contact
we have contact and if i actually visit
one of my posts i can see that showing
up in the title as well
now that we have this in place we have a
really nice site and it's working really
well locally the next and final thing i
want to focus on is actually getting
this up and running in production so
anyone with an internet connection can
check out the site you've created that's
exactly what we're gonna do next so
let's jump right into that
we've got a site and now it's time to
get it live and that's exactly what
we're gonna do in this one now the first
thing we need to do is to get everything
up on a github repo we're gonna end up
using netlify to deploy our static site
and netlify can pull the assets right
from github so that's a really good
solution for us
over here in the editor we can close all
open editors and we can collapse all
expanded directories
and the only thing we're going to do
before we make a commit is make sure
that our environment variable file does
not get committed this can contain
sensitive information and it's something
that we don't want to commit as part of
the repo because right here this is not
stuff we want to expose to just anybody
so to do that what we're going to do is
actually rename this file right here
we're just going to call it dot env
originally i thought i would create
multiple environment files but that's
not the case we just have this one
locally and we can see that by default
it's already ignored based off of the
get ignore file that comes with gatsby
the only other change we need to make
since we renamed that file is over here
in the develop script right here dot env
dot development just becomes dot env
now we're ready to commit our changes
and push them up to github
let's get started by actually creating a
github repo for our new project
so right here i'll go over to github.com
i'm going to create a new repository
and we're going to set this up i'll call
it gatsby bootcamp and i'll leave this
one as private
down below we can create it without
customizing any of the other settings
and once we have it created we're going
to take our existing repository and
pushed that up from the command line
so let's take this first command which
adds the correct remote and we'll head
over to the terminal
now by default all of your gatsby
projects already have a git repository
created so all we need to do is make
sure that our changes and all of our new
files actually become part of the
repository
i will use git status to take a look at
the status of the repo right here we can
see we have a bunch of untracked files
that we're going to want to track and up
above we also have some changes to
existing ones
i'll use git add dot to move all of
those to the staging area and then git
commit to create a commit right here
final
gatsby site
and now that we have this in place we
can push the code up to github
i'll start by pasting in that first
command which sets up the correct remote
then all we have to do is use get push u
we're going to push to origin and we're
going to push up the master branch
and once this command is done we'll be
ready to connect our github repo to the
netlify hosting service to host our
gatsby site
all right i'm seeing everything right
here so let's pull up a new tab it is
netlify.com
this is a great hosting service for
static sites it's an increasingly
popular choice when working with gatsby
because there is direct integration so
it's super easy to manage
and once again everything we're doing
here is completely free there is no
credit card required for any of this
let's take a quick moment to create an
account and i'll work through this
process with you just so we're seeing
the exact same stuff
i'm going to sign up for a new account
now once we sign up we do have to
confirm our email before we can deploy
our site so i'm going to take a quick
moment to pull that up off screen then
we'll continue on with the setup
all right when i click that verification
link this is exactly where i was brought
there's a little quick start guide with
some information about how we can get
started we're going to go ahead and
close that down and work through this
process together what we want is right
here new site from get and we're going
to connect with our github account now
this is going to require us to give
netlify permissions to read some of our
data and right here we can see we have
the option to pick select repositories
or all of our repositories we could go
ahead and just pick one so i could crack
that open and i could find the new one i
created gatsby bootcamp giving it
limited access to just that and down
below we can see we have access to all
of the repository features and we're
going to install that as part of our
github account now once that is
installed we'll actually be able to
select our repository from a list and
once we have that it's going to set up
the build options down below we have the
owner that is me this is the name
automatically generated for me
we have the branch to deploy i'm just
going to deploy master the only branch
we have
and down below we have other things like
the build command and this is correct we
want to leave this and this in place the
public directory is where the static
site is going to live when the gatsby
build command is executed now we also
want to go to show advanced right here
we can set up environment variables for
our environment and we do need to do
that we have those environment variables
locally and those are the only things
getting our site working right here we
don't have to worry about setting up
graphql playground as the graphql api is
not even available in production but we
do want to set up the space id so let's
start with that i'll grab the variable
name
and i'm also going to grab the value
pasting both in
we're going to add the other variable as
well for the access token i'll set up
the name
then i'll go ahead and grab the value
making sure not to grab the equals sign
and now we're actually ready so it's
going to grab the code it's going to run
the build command and serve up that
public directory and it's going to make
sure it can actually get our contentful
assets since we have these values
defined
from here all we need to do is click
deploy site this is going to work
through the deployment process and
especially for the first time this can
take a little longer it can take upwards
of maybe 60 seconds to get everything up
and running so what i'm going to do is
just cut the video to win the deployment
is complete
the deployment is now finished and we
have our url up above let's go ahead and
open that up in a brand new tab and what
do i see we have our site live on the
web right here all of our pages are
working and we also have our contentful
data i have our first post and our
second post
now when it comes to deploying a new
version of your site you have a few
different options so let's go ahead and
make some changes and get a new version
up we're going to change not just the
site code we're also going to change
some data in contentful so we can see
what that process looks like too and i
actually want to start with a change to
the contentful data let's go ahead and
just alter the title of one of our blog
posts right here
we have contentful
i'm going to go ahead and change a
contentful blog post over to something
else
my new post
and i am going to publish those changes
now this alone is not enough to have the
new content showing up remember this is
a static site so when netlify first ran
the build command that's when it fetched
the data and populated things if i
refresh we're never going to see that
new content
so if i just change the content and i
want to show that new content on the
site we can indeed get that done right
over here what we're going to do is go
to the deploys tab for our project and
right here we have a few different
options what we want to do is trigger a
new deploy we're going to clear cache
and deploy site so this is going to go
through the process of recreating our
site once again and here it's just
bringing us over to the deploy logs once
this is done we'll be able to see our
new contentful data and this is actually
a nice thing we can make changes to our
data and once we're ready we explicitly
deploy a new version of our site to view
that new data now let's go ahead and go
back to the overview page for our site
and once that deployment is done
actually let's stick on the deploys page
we can see it's building down below all
we're going to do is refresh the site
once again
so i'm gonna cut the video to when the
new build is done
all right right here i can see my new
build has been published and if we head
over to the site all we need to do is
give things a refresh and we see the new
data showing up so that's the workflow
for changing just the content we update
contentful we trigger a new deploy
manually and then we see our new changes
now let's actually make a change to some
code for the site so i'm going to close
all open editors and we're just going to
change something on the home page so
i'll go to source
pages index.js
right here i'm just going to remove this
paragraph where i link over to the
contact page as i already have that link
in the navigation with that change in
place all we need to do is commit our
changes and push them up to github so
right here git status and we can see the
only changed file is the one that we
changed
then we're gonna run git commit once
again
providing our commit message
clean up home page links
once the commit is in place we have to
use git push to push our code changes up
to github and when this is done we're
gonna see that over in netlify a new
deploy is triggered so by default it is
going to deploy changes from master it's
going to generate a new build and it's
going to publish it so we'll see that
start in just a couple of seconds here
there's no need to manually trigger a
build when we're making code changes we
really only need to manually trigger a
build when working with netlify i'll
give the page a quick refresh just to
see if anything new has been pulled in
and here we have it we have a new build
in progress so this is starting up and
once it's done we should be able to see
our changes over on the site so i'm
going to take a quick moment to cut the
video to when this build is finished
all right that deploy has finished and
now we should be able to see our changes
on the site here i have the home page
i'll give things a refresh and my
paragraph is gone
so that's as easy as it gets working
with netlify allows us to deploy our
site managing our contentful data and
managing changes to our code and now you
know how to work with both of those
now netlify can do so much more than
we're gonna have time to talk about in
this video if we go to overview you can
easily set up a custom domain and enable
https and up above there are a ton of
great features for managing your site
for now though that's all we need to get
gatsby up and running that's where we're
gonna stop for this video and that's
also where we're gonna stop for the boot
camp we've gone through the process of
creating customizing and deploying our
very first gatsby project we can now
continue to work with gatsby and build
off of this to create anything we might
want to build with react
that is it for the great gatsby boot
camp if you want to check out other
content i've created i have more videos
right here on youtube and i also teach
premium classes on udemy covering topics
like javascript react node gis and
graphql i'll include links to all of
that and more in the description down
below once again i'm andrew meade from
mead.io
and i hope to see you in another video
sometime soon